we got major breaking news Joe Biden has
called up U.S military reserves The
Selective reserves and the ready
reserves is a big deal for deployment to
Europe over the war in Ukraine we don't
exactly know what that means other than
uh people are quite worried that two
different uh Reserve groups are being
called up
for deployment into Europe I don't know
if this means we should be prepared for
war but uh certainly it's a very big
deal so we'll definitely be talking
about that we've got some other big news
that may or may not come up Twitter is
now paying people yeah I abruptly Got a
notification saying they are paying me
six grand and uh I'm not that active on
Twitter one of the Brian krasnstein got
25 000 is huge because with this move of
paid Partnerships Twitter is going to
become a very dominant platform on
social media one of the only other
platforms to offer people a way to
monetize their social media presence
Instagram sort of does but for most
people it doesn't really work but most
importantly what we're going to be
talking about quite a bit today is the
film signed to freedom because we're
being joined by the people behind
Saturday sound of Freedom before we get
into all of that however head over to
castbrew.com to support our work by
buying our coffee I gotta be honest
Casper coffee is the best coffee I've
ever had we formulated these Blends
they're fantastic rise with Roberto Jr
breakfast blend the light roast
Appalachian Knights of dark roast check
these out they're available in ground or
hold Bean you can join the cast Brew
Coffee Club buying our coffee helps
support the work that we do here we
decided we're going to sponsor ourselves
with our own company so we have more
control and we don't have to worry about
any kinds of cancellations or people
getting mad at us and actually one of
the hopes we have with Casper aside from
the physical locations is we want to
start sponsoring other channels that we
believe in one so we can sell more
coffee but actually to provide a
guarantee like hey if you do this deal
with us and we buy sponsorship with you
we will never never cancel over any kind
of weird press stuff or angry activists
but you know if we can't sponsor you in
the future it might be normal but we're
never going to cancel somebody so go to
casper.com support us also head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member because we're gonna have a
members only uncensored show and more
importantly if you've been a member for
at least six months or you sign up today
for at least 25 bucks a month you can
submit questions and potentially call
into the show to talk to us and our
guests and I think that one's going to
be uh amazing I'm really excited for
this smash the like button subscribe to
this channel share this show with your
friends because today we are being
joined by Tim Ballard and Eduardo
verastegi
Tim yes sir I think everybody knows who
are you want to introduce yourself yeah
um thanks so much for having us on the
show and uh so I'm I'm the I guess the
subject of sound of Freedom uh I spent
12 years as a special agent undercover
operator for the US government 10 of
those years on the border you see that
there's a there's an important scene
sound of Freedom where a little kid is
rescued at the border true story
um which kind of kicks off the rest of
the The Narrative right uh and then you
know in in 2012 2013 I started
discovering something well let me go
back to 2006. in 2006 the the Lost
change in in the United States with the
passage of something called the Adam
Walsh child protect act what it did was
it allowed U.S agents for the first time
to go overseas and we could if we found
Americans engaging in sex with kids we
could hold them accountable as if they'd
committed that sex crime in the U.S so
that kind of opened up like in
International operations and about that
time I went down to cover school and
they sent me in I'd play the role of a
pedophile a purveyor of child sex
trafficker whatever and we'd go in
um but what happened though the US
government didn't mean to do this but
they kind of tortured me because uh you
know here's the problem child
trafficking knows no borders and
boundaries but bureaucracies do
and so if I'm down there and I find a
kid I don't care what nationality I
don't care what anything it's a kid a
kid's a kid but the laws in the U.S
needed me to find the American wow and
so I'd be like guys let me finish the
case and then we'll find the Americans
later nope that's too creative for
bureaucracy come home
several times this happens breaking my
heart and in 2013 I was actually working
two cases uh one in Haiti crazy story
this little boy named guardy Marty U.S
citizen of Haitian descent two years old
the family moves him back to Haiti he is
kidnapped out of the church where his
father's the pastor oh my God kidnap
traffic I learned about this story I
meet the father I'm thinking this is a
U.S citizen I can I can go find this kid
he was born in Utah and I had been
transferred to Utah recently at that
point
um so I'm working in this case I'm told
come home
this is a Haitian crime but I promised
the father wow I promised the father I
would never stop at the same time I'm
down in Colombia and this is the part
you see in the sound of Freedom
Consulting and I was giving permission
if you listen to the film it's accurate
I was given permission to consult
you know and as you see in the film I
went beyond that and then so then they
said Hey where's the American where's
the leads I said I feel it it's here
come home so that was two in 2013 and I
called my wife
and I was like what do I do like my
heart is breaking like these kids will
be rescued these kids will be rescued
but if I leave I mean I'm debate you
know I'm the I'm the I'm the point on
this case and um
and and she you see in the movie right
where is this how campus going yes
that's why you're here I just keep but
in the movie Mira Sorvino who plays my
wife Academy Award winning amazing
actress
um and it's one of my favorite lines in
the film because it's so powerful it's
much more powerful in real life but she
says
just quit your job and rescue those kids
right and I'm like yeah I'm gonna do it
but that's not what really happened okay
the Eduardo and the team didn't want me
to show the the true cowardice that I
actually manifested at this time in in
late 2013 because it was my idea I said
well Catherine if if I if I come home
you know uh it's over but I keep my job
I have to quit my job to do this I talk
to I mean I was calling the DHS like
ethics office can I do both like no you
can't do both you can't Moonlight you
gotta quit you know or or do the case
um and she said and so her line was
supposed to be
well get your butt home because we got
six kids and and yet we have no money
like we you know we have a couple
thousand you know stocked away you know
um socked away in the bank or something
and and and she didn't say that
she didn't say that she said could you
save the kids if you stayed there I said
yes
yes he's like why it was almost like
embarrassing like why are you even
asking me this question wow she says we
have a meeting with our maker
we will be dead in 50 Years anyway see
and she said I don't care if we live in
a tent these are exactly her words I
don't care for an intent
because we lose our house you have to do
this you have to try and I fought back
like a coward like are you kidding me
what about my own kids I gotta take care
of my own six kids like they'll be fine
um she finally got to the point where
she just gave it to me in one line
that didn't make it in the movie because
again it would have manifested my
cowardice
um but one line that's this is verbatim
it ended the debate it shook me to my
core because he's usually very sweet
and she said and it's a quote I will not
let you jeopardize my salvation by not
doing this
and I remember my whole body's kind of
shook I was just like oh my gosh oh my
gosh like that is an incredible woman
yeah there is so much we were already
talking before the show and there's
gonna be more spoilers so
um someone conveniently we'll talk a
little bit about what's going on with
Europe which will give us a little
buffer zone so I can warn everybody and
say there's gonna be spoilers uh We're
not gonna go crazy with it but I think
we definitely need to talk about some of
the elements of the film because it was
it was so good stories like that
the feeling that I got watching this was
I could not believe it I thought it was
just good writing and then you tell me
actually those were true
so thank you for for joining us we also
have Eduardo here do you want to
introduce yourself as well yes very
grateful to be here with all of you
thank you so much for supporting sound
of Freedom thank you so much for this
interview and uh I'm the producer of the
film
eight years of work eight years of work
since I met Tim Ballard I met him in Los
Angeles California eight years of work
for two hours of your time
which is what the movie Last and I hope
this film keep touching millions of
Hearts five million people already can
you believe it unbelievable people show
up in the last 10 days 54 million
dollars about so far and uh we're
hearing more and more theaters are
starting to get packed word of mouth is
spreading this is the stories that the
story you just told
the stories in the film this feels like
more than a movie this is something more
powerful I mean I will not let you what
did she say jeopardize Myself by not
doing this this is wow this is good for
you seriously thank you guys for coming
we're gonna we're gonna be I would say
for the most part we're gonna be talking
all about this but uh for the time being
we got Sheamus hanging out I'm a
cartoonist an animator I don't do
anything that impressive uh I write
jokes and and do comedy uh I have a
YouTube channel called Freedom tunes and
I am really excited to be joined by both
of you this film was incredible I've
been recommending it to my audience into
Tim's audience non-stop what you've
built is is incredible and Tim the work
you've done is unbelievably inspiring
thank you so much it is man and that's
that same conversation for whatever
reason that was when I broke down the
first time in that movie when she said
do it like go go you know I mean I I
it's a it's a moment
let's keep moving this along baby thank
you for coming minutes
okay let's go Serge Dupree yes uh
iamsurge.com I'm excited to hear you
guys uh just tell us kind of more about
the story in general and uh yeah let's
just get into it we're gonna take a
quick 10 minute little buffer to give
you guys some breaking news this is from
the post millennial Biden calls up U.S
military Reserve units to deploy to
active duty in Europe in operation
Atlantic resolve Atlantic resolve is the
official name of the unofficial
operation supporting the war in Ukraine
that is to say reserve military actually
let me just pull up the executive order
we have right here from the from the
white house.gov selected reserve and the
individual ready reserve of the armed
forces are being called to active dirty
active duty to be deployed into Europe
the the official white house.gov
statement is by the authority vested to
me as president
et cetera et cetera and he lists
everything I hear by determine is
necessary to augment the active Armed
Force of the U.S for the effective
conduct of operation Atlantic resolve in
and around the United States European
commands area of responsibility now
I'm not a military guy I don't know
exactly what this means
but it certainly sounds like we are
inching closer to a major conflict
related to Russia potentially a World
War III scenario
I don't know what else to say other than
what do you guys think about it uh do
you guys have any knowledge experience
what do you guys think
yeah I'm I'm certainly frightened by the
news I'm probably not the person here
who has the most expertise on Military
and foreign policy but I think there's
real reason to be concerned let's pray
for this country and hope that we don't
get dragged into a third world war that
this doesn't escalate into something
that it doesn't need to be it's like I
believe that there is God that it's like
a real uh structure structure something
that's happening that's vibrating and
causing things to form like they're
happening like chimatics cymatics you
see where sound can cause matter to
change shape and that maybe we're here
to talk about this movie because these
War stuff is out of our hands we can
only
explain it yeah it's it's a it's a crazy
time yeah I'll tell you this I was in
I've been to Ukraine several times last
year
um and so my my perspective is a little
different where I actually like what
Trump said about I want people to stop
dying like well let's de-escalate not
not escalate uh I spent time out there
uh crazy story again my wife again uh
February 23rd I think it was last year
Russia invades Ukraine my wife comes up
to me in tears oh my gosh you got to go
to Ukraine and get those kids out like
we're kids well we adopt children out of
Ukraine as part of one of the
foundations that she runs called
Children and Families we had seven kids
on the way out and she said go get them
I'm like I'll call the teams like no you
have to go I'm like Catherine like the
bombs are dropping like she's like I
know and she's crying and she's saying
it because she's very deliberate so when
she's irrational as God
I know that's God when she's saying and
I kid you not create and he can verify
the story three hours later after
Catherine's telling me this I get a
phone call from Mel Gibson
and Mel Gibson says hey I got these kids
and and Ukraine these orphans who are I
think they're in the war zone can you go
get him out
and I'm like what like do science right
there I've always been brought up with
the notion that if your wife and Mel
Gibson both tell you to do something you
know you probably better listen you
better listen anyway we went out there
worked with a group called aerial
recovery I'm on the board amazing group
6 000 women children got out so the
suffering that we saw and by the way I
won't get into this except we found a
pedophile group that was trafficking
children out of Ukraine into Mexico into
Ecuador crazy case Tony Robbins produced
the docuseries about it he's going to be
a producer as well but that's a
different story but my point is stop
de-escalating this thing the pain that
we're seeing the suffering that we're
seeing on the ground the part that no
one remembers traffickers call this
Harvest Time a war a hurricane an
earthquake in the aftermath Harvest Time
how is it a 150 billion dollar business
human trafficking how do you get that
many kids into that black market Harvest
Time Wars
hurricanes earthquake and it's happening
and no one that's the least reported
thing kids losing their parents kids
losing their parents this place this
place a nice van pulls up hey sweetie
get in the car we'll take care of you
next thing they wake up in in the
Caribbean like in Haiti I mean tell the
story when you went to uh save this
little kid what happened in the
orphanage I mean that's crazy man how
you know volunteers from all over the
world going to Haiti to you know find
children that they love their parents
because in one night thousands of
children
yep these traffickers just right they
just tried orphanage on the wall it's
it's his whether you think literally or
figuratively demonic oh yeah and it is
crazy to hear you're telling the story
here we are you know we're going to talk
about the film and your background we're
talking about the war and here you are
telling the story where your wife
Annabelle Gibson both call you and say
go save these kids you know part of me
is like I'm thinking there's a lot of
people who wish they would have some
kind of
the purpose being laid right before them
you have a job and I have to wonder
because I would imagine it's kind of
scary
but it's also a situation where you
can't say no exactly both both of those
you know people I'm just as scared as
anyone else going into Ukraine or going
into these these places I'll say this
though God is real and he loves children
because
every time once we're on the ground and
looking and there it goes away I don't
know I can't explain it it goes away and
I'm clear-minded I'm not I'm not worried
I'm not I'm not afraid to die in that
moment then afterwards I come I just
told you I can't watch out of freedom
it triggers me you know it's it I I'm
scared again after you know it's like
God will bless you in the moment you're
doing what he wants you to do but then
then you got to deal like you got to
deal with it before and after so what
made you decide in the beginning to get
involved rescuing kids
well I I I was my first job with the CIA
I was there through 9 11 and when I
learned about Muhammad Atta who was a
terrorist across over the border of
Mexico into the U.S and then and then
launched his attack I want to be on that
border so I I trained anti-trafficient
anti-terrorism stuff I have a graduate
degree in a certificate in
anti-terrorism so I got put on that
border that's where I wanted to be I
speak Spanish six months later they
asked me to be in the group child crimes
I said no so there's no way I'm going to
go in that group
um and my wife's agreed with me and then
the next morning before I said no she
she didn't sleep all night she was
crying and she said we have to say yes
oh my gosh if how can we be so fearful
of our own pain
uh that uh that we would disregard
severe pain beyond our comprehension of
these children so
Jesus I don't mean it's all about my
wife today
This Woman's dragging you to heaven man
and I'm going Kicking and Screaming
hopefully I'm going if
you know I don't know maybe maybe it's
inappropriate to say but uh if ever
there was someone with some kind of
Divine Purpose this the story that
you've told already I'm like man how
many people just wish they knew they had
that mission whether they whether they
were fearful of it or not like I said
it's probably scary but you tell these
stories and and so much of it sounds
unreal
the line from your wife the story from
the film story in a minute but
man it really does feel like you have a
purpose here that you are fulfilling I I
have to think I think so yeah I feel
that I feel that yeah I mean you're um
you're a humble man and you're saying
these things about the fact that you
were afraid and and your wife encouraged
you and surely she did but there are
many men whose wives would say save
those children who'd go we're not
talking about this honey absolutely not
yeah that's like I said I her script was
supposed to read get your ass home
because I got too many kids here what
would be like in the future what would
be your ideal outcome
for you
I whatever I'm gonna do I'm I I it'll be
attached always to this to this cause
because once you see it's like you can't
unring a bell right once you see it and
I'm hoping people are having this
experience with sound of Freedom now
because once you see it you cannot unsee
it and when the to the depths I've gone
it would be like I could never walk away
from from this work you know in some
capacity my undercover days are shot for
sure that's
you know thanks to this guy he he ruined
my undercover career but maybe maybe
we'll Inspire many more people that's
what we hope so yeah that's what we are
tenfold that's 100 fold that's right not
to I mean outside of that uh we we talk
about uh the great work you've done the
film was masterfully done I thought it
was one of the best films I've seen in a
very very long time just in terms of the
production the the pacing the story
everything I think you guys nailed it
it's it's you know if you take a great
story and you do it wrong the story
doesn't make it you make a great film
you hit out of the park now that story
that mission makes it somewhere I think
people often underestimate the
importance of filmmaking and making sure
people feel that emotion in that story
you know I think for me as a producer
the number one thing that you need to
have is the story the story is like the
is the soul of the movie without a good
story you have nothing right so when I
met him mother eight years ago in Los
Angeles California I was with Alejandro
Monte Verde my business partner he's the
director of the film and he's the writer
of the film as well along with Rod bar
and when we met him and he told us what
he does around the world him and his
friends his you know his team they
travel around the world undercover
rescuing children that are kidnapping
sex Transportation kids that are being
abused 10 to 15 times a day for many
years and then after that sometimes they
you know they don't want them anymore
because there's you know they're not you
know they're not fresh meat anymore
that's that's the vocabulary that they
use right so they go to uh this second
business which is organs traffic they
open them and they sell their organs so
when you heard things like this man you
cannot look the other way around anymore
or you you have to do something and and
I remember like yesterday when Tim
baller looked at me and he said Eduardo
Alejandro I know it's very sad what I'm
telling you I know that it's very sad
what I'm telling you about this children
the pain that they're going through but
it's more sad now that you know it if
you do nothing what are you gonna do and
and I knew at that time in Alejandro as
well that we we had to do something
we're filmmakers we have a weapon of
mass instruction and inspiration right
well let's make let's make a movie
because movies move people and media
influence how people think but let me
ask you a few questions first this is a
global problem right yes especially U.S
and Mexico us is the number one consumer
of child sex
Mexico number one provider
okay okay team
if you live in the most powerful country
in the world you have the technology the
intelligence the money the the you know
the Army the police everything how come
we don't finish this problem in United
States and he said because it's not a
priority it's not a priority we are not
the solution Eduardo I can be the
solution for one child for one thousand
for three thousands we're talking about
millions of children around the world
that are kidnapped for sex
transportation we need a movement
and that's when I realized hold on a sec
hold on a second you know a movie has
the potential to start a movement so
let's make a movie tell us what's the
most difficult Rescue Mission you've
ever done in your life the most
dangerous the most successful one he
said Cartagena Colombia the first one
tell me the story and he tells the story
and then we ask him what happened when
the kids were rescue oh man they were
crying with tears in their eyes they
were celebrating their freedom by by
singing it was like this sound of
Freedom that's the title and that's a
story then Alejandro right after he
started writing the script for three
years three years of uh Alejandro's life
and you know what happened to him right
before he started writing the script man
his father and his older brother got
kidnapped in Mexico wow and and they
killed him
Alejandro Monte Verde wrote Sound of
Freedom with so much pain man he put his
soul his blood his suffering in that
movie and I know when people see this
movie sound of Freedom they feel the
pain of the kids they feel the sacrifice
of Tim Ballard they feel the pain of the
writer Alejandro Monte Verde and we are
honoring his father and his son with
this film too as well who are in heaven
along with my father who passed away
passed away last year I want to jump to
this right here from Box Office Mojo
sound of Freedom though it's been
attacked relentlessly by many in the
media it has cracked 50 million with a
current domestic box office of 53
million 920 22 551 and massive Success
Through Word of Mouth more and more
people are starting to see this film it
looks like the amount of uh gross
revenue being generated is increasing
whereas most films have their big
Blockbuster weekend it goes down this is
the inverse I think this film really is
potentially a starting a movement more
and more people are are getting active
focusing on the issue more people care
about the issue there are creepy people
in the media that are smearing it as Q
Anon and other weird things but get this
even with that on Rotten Tomatoes The
Tomato Meter which is the official
corporate press reviewers give it a 75
percent that surprised me the audience
gives it a 100 with over 10 000 verified
ratings
I gotta say we have been praising this
film I think Not only was it masterfully
done it is an entertaining fill it
captures you it makes you feel
at the same time that feeling matters I
watch I watch movies every day I watch a
different movie every day I've gone to
the theaters yeah I might get a tear in
the eye or something for a good scene I
might get excited for a good scene but
none of it matters you know I know that
Captain America fighting somebody is
just fun but when I watch a film that's
based on a true story and I see a scene
in that film
that I couldn't believe was real and I'm
I'm tearing up I was let me let me put
let me put it this way because we're
gonna start getting into spoilers now
there is a part of the film so a warning
to all of you who still want to go see
the movie and don't want to see don't
want to hear spoilers we're telling you
right now but for everyone else who did
we're gonna start getting into some of
the finer details so we can better
understand this because I wanna I wanna
talk about
one of the most powerful things I've
made reference to in the two weeks or a
week or so ago it is when you rescue
this kid on the border so again spoilers
here we go
you are talking to this child
you tell the child your name
and the kid looks up at you and he says
timoteo
he has a necklace that was given to him
by his sister
with Saint Timothy I believe is the uh
what was it first Timothy is first
Timothy 6 11 scripture reference yeah
and he and and when I saw that first of
all my name's Tim so I was just like
whoa like that's crazy for me to hear
and your name's Tim too I know but like
I'm watching this movie this kid is
being rescued from this evil evil man
and this organization you say this is my
name and then he pauses and it seems to
be some kind of like divine intervention
when he says look what I have as if you
were sent specifically to save him I was
on the verge of tears when I saw that
happen I said I'm like yeah but I wish
that really happened and then you told
me it did it happened and I and I told
Alejandro I said because I have the
necklace I mean I have it's a so it's
like Priceless to me I have it in a
vault you know and I took it out for my
to do podcasts and things I should have
brought it here but
um I said don't put this in because No
One's Gonna believe it then it's gonna
come off weird and what are the chances
and and uh and and people still don't
think it's real but they still like it
so he was right but it's great to be
able to say it actually happened and it
was a strange moment where um uh
he he you know and it's very accurate it
didn't happen in the garage like you see
uh and the film happened in a different
room uh in the Aftercare Center but he
runs to me and he hugs me and the part
that didn't they didn't pick up in the
film was we were sobbing I'm shaking and
he's shaking and that's before I got the
necklace that's before he just starts
grabbing me and he says to me
um and I think
this was the kind of transformational
moment for me because I didn't know if I
was going to stay in this work
um especially after this this is the
first kid I ever saw by the way who was
in a video
before that time I'd only done videos
like you know end user you know
possession cases of child exploitation
material this was the first time when I
saw this kid I knew him I recognized him
I had seen him being raped his full like
through a 30 minute video
and the his captor was the guy in the
video
so I'm already on heightened like oh my
gosh it's a real kid this is you know I
never I never seen it and and so we're
I'm coloring with him okay Prager you
you know Prager you oh yeah today today
prageru launched a series called light
in the darkness where they have me
telling some of these stories this
story's told and and is dramatized in a
really cool way and it's more accurate
this and we're sitting there and we're
coloring I'm trying to get him to talk
because where's your sister where are
the other kids like where he's five
years old right and and up until that
point we've just been kind of friendly
we got close he started trusting me and
it was like just like this like
something just turned on in him and he
just ran over to me and jumped into my
arms like almost like again it was like
an angel said go or something like he
was he didn't ease into it we're just
coloring and then boom he gets up and
runs to me and he jumps into my arms and
he starts shaking crying and I'm crying
like I just lose it you know I've got to
kiss his age you know you start
picturing your own kids you superimpose
your kids faces in the moment right
um and he says these words to me
and it just it is I couldn't I knew at
that time that the stats were millions
of kids so I heard him say this it's
like I heard echoed millions of kids
saying this and it's a simple phrase but
a five-year-old should never have to say
it and he just said
I don't belong here
can you imagine a five-year-old kid
saying I don't belong here no
five-year-old kid would even think to
say that and you know and and he knew he
belonged with his family and and that's
when he pulled the necklace
and he said he said this is my sister
gave me this
and I I didn't take it I was like oh no
no you keep it you give me a little card
so you see the car in the movie he gave
me the card too and and and I took it
home and I was so broken up I went home
and and Prager you gets into this and
there's in the series as well they just
launched it today
um and I go home and I fall down I fall
down on the I live 10 to 12 minutes from
the border like you know it's all it's a
small town and I fall down and the
dichotomy of the whole I walk into my
house my kids are happy and they're
playing and they're 10 minutes away from
this kid who has spent the first five
years of his life being sexually
assaulted and videotaped you know and my
kids are happy and only 10 minutes away
and I couldn't deal with it it was like
the underbelly of my own town like and
that's everybody's town and it was so
hard for me remember this is the first
kid that I've seen and I Collapse on the
floor and Catherine thought I was like
having a heart attack because I I never
had this happen I was exhausted to it it
was 48 hours or longer I hadn't slept
because the case was so intense and she
didn't know details but she kind of
cradled me like kind of held me you know
um
and she was like what is going on and I
tried to like get it out and I that's
when I made the decision I I said
Catherine I'm either in a thousand
percent or I'm a thousand percent out
like I have to make a decision right now
because this is too much then my other
kid who's about the same age as this
little boy who plays Miguel's not his
real name but in the film my kid who's
his age takes the necklace he's like
what's this
my kids Jimmy and he says what's this
and uh and I said oh this kid gave it to
me I can't tell Jimmy all what's going
on you know this kid I just helped he's
like oh cool he's looking at it become
curious Jim he's a very curious kid he's
very touchy he looks at everything he's
like oh the kid put your name on it wow
I didn't see it before
um it says man of God on one side on the
other side it says first Timothy 6 11.
with that scripture and he's like how
did how do you put your name on it Dad
oh my God he didn't no no he did it and
then he shows it to me and there's like
boom my there's my decision that's it's
a thousand percent in I know that for
the sake of filmmaking you guys had to
do it the way you did and it was
masterfully done but that story I'm
sorry is just told naturally is about
it's better here you are not realizing
what you've been given you go home and
you're saying we make this decision and
then your kid's like he gave you your
name tag yeah oh I don't I just want to
say as I'm hearing all this uh
I I don't follow any particular religion
I do believe in God and
atheists or whatever can call me naive
they can scoff but I don't know how you
hear a story like this how you watch a
film like this how you hear about the
work that you've done how you see a
movement like this and believe that
there's not something out there
something more powerful this I can only
describe as and and I'm not maybe it's
not for me to say but I can say divine
intervention I can say it brother I mean
all glory to God I'm holding the
American dream right now as a Mexican
filmmaker eight years of work so many
obstacles so many people saying you
can't do this this is too dangerous
team telling me brother before you guys
commit to do this I need to tell you
something we have a lot of friends
but we have a lot of enemies too and
those enemies will be yours are you sure
you want to do this and I close my eyes
for a second I said what if this is my
son what if this is my daughter what if
this is what if this is my
my niece my my nephew what would I do
you know it was like it was just imagine
that
I will stop everything that I'm doing I
would hope that I will hope that the
entire world will stop everything
they're doing so they can help me to
find my son my daughter my niece my
nephew right okay so that's my
motivation don't wait until this tragedy
happens to you for you to wake up right
Wake Up Now do something and and and I
can't believe that
you know Angel Studios is the smallest
this region company in America right so
after three years of everyone passing
like no this is not for us now this
movie is not a business for US ah this
is not a good business for us this is
not for us so three years of like doors
being close and close and close and
close and you have two options either
you give up or you don't give up we
choose the second one we don't give up
why because it's about saving children
what if this is your son what happened
after I I'm praying for God to send an
angel to rescue this film
and I got a phone call from Angel
Studios hey uh we're very interested in
your movie do you have any other options
no you're my only option okay well let's
close the deal five days later we send a
contract and okay this is three and a
half months ago right three and a half
months ago and then okay when when when
are we coming out July 4th what brother
we don't have I mean we don't have like
money for publicity or marketing the
biggest films in the world are going to
come out July 4th week before and week
after mission impossible Indiana Jones
competing with the biggest company in
the world they have hundreds of millions
of dollars are you kidding Eduardo
is very important July 4th because it's
Independence Day Freedom we need to
check the conscience of America because
yes let's celebrate let's celebrate
freedom in one hand but let's do
something else so we can bring freedom
back to those children that are not free
brother let's do something we never
thought that July 4th son of Freedom was
number one movie in America this is a
miracle we
all glory to God people like to make
jokes that we live in a simulation
yeah and it's because reality seems to
be too absurd we've had so many weird
goings on in politics of President
Donald Trump and so you'll see many of
these individuals who are secular
atheists tweet things like I hope the
writers of this season you know do X Y
or Z as if to imply there is someone
with greater power over us that they're
starting to believe yet I always find it
funny that they could entertain such an
idea without realizing like you're
literally talking about Divine Purpose
or God
I bring that up because
seeing seeing the movie hearing the
stories
it feels like I'm like I mentioned the
timateo necklace thing I'm like that was
masterful writing I wish it was real
well it was real and then you start to
realize that some things in life
are are so miraculous that you would
assume it was written to be a story that
it never could really happen but these
things do happen
when that kid when you when you told the
story of the of the little kid saying I
don't belong here no five-year-old
should say that
my thought was why would a five-year-old
say that unless what was happening was
so out of alignment with the the law of
nature whatever you want to call it with
with the with God's plan or whatever
that there was direct intervention to
correct this evil and said it right
absolutely and little little did I know
you know
like when you get to the Columbia scene
and I remember being in Colombia and I'm
meeting these guys and this is after
I've left the government and it's our
one of our first big operations and and
I remember thinking
man like No One Believes me like I go
home and tell them my family and friends
I have a very small audience at this
time right this isn't real like 11 year
old kids people want to have sex with 11
year old come on and I remember thinking
I was going through a whole island scene
and you see the whole Columbia scene
most of the movie It's filmed on
location by the way where these things
happened including this the van scene
with the kid at the Port of Entry they
filmed it Homeland Security gave us
permission to film right in this very
place where it happened that's that's
why I can't watch the film it's too much
for me but I remember thinking I wish I
had a I wish I had cameras in my eyes I
remember having that thought and said
millions of people could watch what I'm
seeing because they don't believe it and
so who would have thought like I said
another miracle that like eight nine
years later literally millions of people
would see it through my eyes through
because of this guy
and to you for your sacrifice team and
because if he meeting a hero a true hero
it changed your life no but here's the
thing is I'm not that because I love
history okay we had slavery in this
country at a time horrific nothing worse
than the transatlantic slave trade how
did it end uh you know we can rescue one
the 100 000 whatever just like Harriet
Tubman who's my hero of all time but who
ended it and it wasn't even Lincoln when
Lincoln met Harry Beecher Stowe who
wrote Uncle Tom's Cabin for the first
time in the middle of the Civil War he
said to her so you're the little lady
that wrote The Big Book
that started this war wow he was what he
was saying was because he at that point
in 1862 he had changed the purpose of
the Civil War to just bringing the union
back to no we're gonna we're gonna use
this to liberate the captive and and it
was Harry Potter Frederick Douglass
Harriet Tubman all the the great
abolitionists they changed it they
converted him to the true cause and so
he I I'm so tired of you calling me like
a hero or whatever because like what's
gonna end this thing is you and you and
you like the storytellers are gonna end
this I can't do it I can the
storytellers change culture and this I
mean look at the screen it's 53 million
dollars in 10 days
5 million people in 10 days like this
could change history yeah and this could
change it more films
more movies more culture building
more change you know like this is this
is beyond just this one story one of the
reasons I'm so adamant about telling
people to go see this is that
Hollywood is some dark dark stuff man we
we've seen these actors come out and
talk about what happened to them in
Hollywood there have been some recent
stories of uh celebrities when they were
kids how they were abused and exploited
that's an evil place and not everybody's
there I know I've I know people who work
there but there's got to be a way that
we can build something else and this is
a path towards that as well I wanted to
I wanted to add though uh I'll say a
couple things
in the beginning of the film
uh Jim Caviezel and you obviously in
real life
had to watch these videos I don't know
how you do it I I there that scene where
the other agent says I don't think I can
do this I'm thinking to myself how is a
job like this possible because
spoilers I I know I warned you in the
film I don't know how true to life the
the direct lines or whatever but uh
your character
you know you you go to this pedophile
and you say that in watching these films
you can't help but be attracted to it
and um I'm watching this thinking like
the the
I I don't see that as being a physical
mental possibility for me I imagine that
if if I was in a circumstance I'd quit
on the spot the moment anyone tried to
bring anything up I'd punch the monitor
and I got to be completely honest
watching this film I'm in the middle of
it and I'm thinking am I wrong about the
death penalty
that that's how seriously I was moved by
this I'm very anti-death penalty but
seeing
this message made me really just start
to think about what the founding fathers
meant how they went through this what
does it what does it really mean and it
really challenged my my moral views on
how
how we deal with crimes like this
the the
that that's that's that's how I'll
phrase it and and ultimately I would say
I'm still very much opposed to death
penalty but when you watch this you
challenge you yeah challenged me like
these these people and the crimes they
have committed against children is the
most heinous thing in my mind imaginable
yeah you you talk about passion murders
and and things like that and those are
at the top murder being one of the worst
possible things you can do
but you know when it comes to a lot of
these crimes of passion and planning
there is some underlying purpose about
greed there's some there's some you know
uh sin uh one of the seven deadly sins
associated with it and that's why it's
near the top
but this abuse of children I think
the worst crime imaginable yeah and my
view is if if murder
of an individual warrants the death
penalty why would not this the most
heinous of all crimes imaginable
and uh that that's that's a that's a
deep challenge for me ultimately where I
land the death penalty is I just don't
trust the government enough to
accurately deal out Justice minimum
hundred hundred years of jail minimum
yes for anybody
but that's there's still the innocence
and the beauty of a child locked up
forever
minimum there are people who have abused
children who have been convicted of
abusing children in a court of law and
have served their sentences and now
they're just out in public how can you
serve a sentence for that crime how can
we exactly that's one of the highest
recidivism rates that's true with sex
crimes generally speaking and they just
let these people back out on the streets
like that to be your neighbor if you
have a child yeah well this is so this
this happened too I've talked about this
before Brian pack he was convicted of
abusing a child and then after he was
released from prison what the court said
is he was not allowed to work with
children he previously worked at the
Disney Channel the Disney Channel hired
him back but to speak to them over the
phone and consult over the phone so he
wouldn't be around children why why is
this man out of prison why does this man
have a job why would these networks want
to continue working with him it's
sickening so what I want to ask and I
actually do think it would be I'd like
to bring Ian into this one
uh I I don't even know how to ask it but
you mentioned that before you rescued
this kid you have to watch these videos
yeah how could you possibly so I'll tell
you I I have a million holes burned in
my brain that's how I describe it and
yes that one of the hardest scenes for
me to watch is in fact the scene where
you were you know Jim's crying it's I
can't tell you how real that is I don't
know a couple thousand hours maybe over
10 years having to watch these videos
and these aren't you know I remember
talking to my a friend once and they're
like oh come on I mean how can you tell
the difference between a 17 year old and
an 18 year old I'm like you think that's
what child porn is child exploitation
material we got bro we're talking seven
six five we don't have time to get into
like adolescent miners like it is
there's been a five thousand percent
increase in those kind of sex videos in
the last just decade and it's only going
up uh and and so that burns a hole in
your brain and then the other thing that
burns a hole in your brain is under
cover work and that is true the story is
true the oshenski character very real
case I provided Alejandra with a one
hour and 20 minute interview where I'm
talking to this guy special agent Tim
Ballard talking to oshensky and he won't
break and he is a pedophile like
extraordinary he's got two million
pieces of child exploitation material
videos everything categorized cataloged
just like you see in the film and he
won't break he won't tell me that he
where he was hiding it he was hiding in
his house and the floorboards we ended
up finding it how I broke him I kicked
the agent out I said hey give me let me
try this this is crazy crazy idea I'm
wired up and I start going into what his
literature is I read his books and stuff
online every man is a pedophile but the
puritanical Society has crushed the
human Spirit of sexuality and blah blah
blah blah so I'm like okay let's let's
test it and I went in I went in and
tried to convince him that I am you know
I it's easy when I'm it's easier when
I'm Brian black that's one of the
undercover names I once used or you know
you get to be a different person this
was me being undercover as me Tim
Ballard special agent closet pedophile
and how can I help myself because I have
the largest collection of child
exploitation material on the planet in
in the evidence Vault he fell for it he
fell for it and I and I sent that I
showed Alejandro I said listen to this
he called me freaking out he was shaking
he was like bro I can't believe this how
sick this guy is and how dark you had to
get and he's like I gotta figure out how
to take an hour and 20 minute interview
and reduce it to like two minutes and
you see how he does in the movie he he
does a pretty good job with the
cigarette I won't say more but that's a
very real thing that burned another
million holes in my brain I wonder if I
walked out of that and I it shows Jim's
splashing water I walked you around the
side of the house I vomited outside
right by the tire of my car I remember I
vomited and uh
you make there's a line that Jim
Caviezel says you mentioned was was
ad-libbed yes it's so it's so good that
scene was absolutely incredible yeah
when people are cheering for the for the
good guys in that I'm I'm but uh Ian the
reason I wanted to uh bring you into
this is Ian used to moderate for a
social media website I don't know the
degree to the awful things you you saw
in doing moderation I didn't even not
even hold a candle to what you've been
through man or what you've seen it was
I'd see every once in a while I'd see a
leg get blown off I I'd see I didn't
ever see a little kid naked and I don't
ever want to uh no no but it was I had
to it broke me after and I kept doing it
and it kept breaking me and then I
I just kept doing it because it was one
I had to if someone had to do it I don't
think human minds are supposed to be
able to look at that stuff no way no
they say that uh people who work at
Facebook and these social media
platforms this kind of stuff gets
uploaded you know there's different
degrees I'm not saying just one kind of
awful content there's varying degrees of
really bad stuff from someone just
getting mercilessly attacked to murdered
to child exploitation and there are
stories about these Facebook employees
who are completely traumatized from
working this job where they're trying to
remove this stuff and I think people
should realize
that that was one of the reasons I think
the film is so good because that issue
right there
like understand man there there are
people who if if you don't watch it how
do you stop these guys you've got to
prove in a court of law you've got to
have them arrested you have to have them
stand trial
and the evidence has to be shown that's
right well I I don't you want to share
like for example this is this is not in
the movie because I mean it's very
difficult to make a movie about this guy
when he's telling you like so many
beautiful powerful like uh stories you
know about saving children and you have
only two hours I said brother we need to
we need to do a TV series because I need
like 200 episodes to tell your story you
know so that's why it's very difficult
but that when someone asks you what is
the hottest thing ever happened to you
and you and you said well smiling smile
to the face of evil yeah can you explain
because that happened there but it's not
in the movie but that is like man when
you share the story I was like I would
have killed the guy well that's the part
about the the other million holes in
your brain like it's one thing to see
the images but then you gotta hang with
these guys and you got to hang with them
for months sometimes and you're your you
hang out all day all night you're you're
their buddies your business partners and
how do you do it like this messes with
your brain because you there's chemistry
with the brain like connection right
there's yeah you can't fake it so you
have to like dig down hard and find the
humanity in them there's something good
redeeming in their in their heart and
there's usually something and you gotta
like grab it and try to love it because
you can't fake it that long do you think
there's there's sorry there's a scene in
the film
where you're on the island
and the the Don I think his name was
right
tries taking one of the cards yeah and
you intervene your character intervenes
yeah
it's the scene where you're trying to
sting these guys save these kids
law enforcement is ready
but before before the rest of the kids
arrive because you don't know where
they're at
this guy tries to rape a child yeah
your character I don't I don't know if
this is absolutely true is that how it
happened or whatever your character
intervenes no this one's this one's mine
and the guy puts a gun to his head and
says step out of the way yeah and that's
a scary thought that
I don't know you can answer to this
circumstances where you have to collect
information to shut these guys down
but if you stop them in the moment you
jeopardize the whole mission and it
could put a hundred kids lives at risk
but that kid right there needs saving
now right I I could not imagine how you
make a what you do in a moment like this
other than I would assume just save that
kid but
what you have to do is ahead of time set
it up so you don't find yourself in
those situations so in full in full
transparency that scene was was
fictionalized
um it was a cool scene right because it
was it brought this intensity and it it
showed me and vampida working together
which is that's true in Spirit uh we
work together he's a very real guy the
Vampiro character very real and
um but you we we plan out ahead of time
to where on that operation and others
like that we would never let them be in
the same space yeah so we put the kids
somewhere else candy games we have
operators female operators who are
nurses pretending to be the groomers
that that's what traffickers think
getting the kids ready and then we
separate we lure them with the money if
you want the money you better come over
here one time we did an app where we put
we put a yacht out off the coast
you got to come to the yacht and we're
gonna do the deal out there that's how
far we'll separate them so those kind of
things never actually have to have to
happen did you um having spent time with
like pedophiles pederos because file
means love like familial Love philia is
Like Love of friend but it's Eros it's
erotic love correct yeah
they call it that's well they don't but
they should yeah you're right yeah do
you find that there is a Road to
Redemption for people that have gone
through that
huh I want to say yes because I love
Redemption stories but I've never seen
it I've never seen Vampiro a little bit
well then Peter actually didn't he
actually didn't uh rape it rape a child
he was he was having he was involved
with the prostitute who was selling her
child and when he saw that so Alejandro
played with that a little bit you're
right he thought it was like an older
and then when then he yeah so now that
she was like 13 years old and that's
when he said oh my gosh but I don't
think he actually was with somebody who
was underage no he was he was actually
never with someone under age so this is
for those that haven't seen it you know
for context I know it is spoilers but uh
this is someone you were working with to
try and stop the exploitation of kids
correct the reason I asked if there's a
Road to Redemption or you would think is
because like Tim you mentioned it it
tested your morality or your your your
thoughts on the death penalty started
creeping and when I was watching the
movie I was thinking surveillance State
why don't we have a surveillance state
to watch for these and to take to
prevent this stuff and like because a
surveillance state would be horrific and
you were saying you wish that you had
cameras in your eyes like they can do
that that could be the future but I
don't think that's better I'll I'll tell
you why
because Epstein was a real guy
and when we make laws and we give power
to government under the assumption it
will always be good bad people find a
way to exploit that power in some way in
very very awful and dangerous ways to
the point where Epstein was actually I
think he was caught early on and he got
some kind of sweetheart deal and then
was released now you've got well
Epstein's no longer here but he's
arrested Maxwell was convicted and so we
think that we enact these laws of
surveillance state for instance we'll
stop them no
sooner or later a bad person exploits
the system takes advantage of it and now
we're underneath them wielding that
power against us which makes it very
difficult so there's got to be some
balance that's right I'm not going to
pretend to be the expert on how we do it
or how it should be done but we have to
be careful about giving too much power
to one institutional organization unless
it be wielded in negative ways maybe I'm
getting ahead of myself because I think
what a big part of the solution is like
you were saying like the uh
the it's the the storytelling it's
letting people know that it happened
um but what I'm like chomping at the bit
like what is it just more undercover
sting operations
it is and I'll tell you why after that
operation in Colombia happened
um again I wish the film were 10 hours
so you can see everything that happened
um we went back
that was such a big hit in fact it was
underreported in the film 54 rescues it
was 120 rescues in two different
locations and there's a documentary DNA
films it's an emmy-winning documentary
no one's seen it yet Angel Studios is
putting it out called triple take and it
dissects everything that happened on
that island but after we did those three
hits 120 rescues 15 traffickers down
um we went back under different
undercover faces we sent them in and
asked the same people who otherwise
would have introduced you to the
traffickers and everyone was like don't
even talk about that don't you know what
happened these Americans came down don't
you got to see the papers and we're just
inside going it's working yes it's
working for the first time these guys
are looking over their shoulder for the
first time there's some kind of a
consequence that can can make the
barrier to entry into this black market
of child slavery you know too high to
enter I do love them saying the
Americans came down they're scared they
know that they are people who will stop
them right I love this story man the the
the
idea of some kind of divine intervention
and the idea of just the plain old
physical reality in which you are saving
kids you are telling this story gives me
hope makes me believe in the good makes
me feel like you know I don't understand
how someone out there could be a
nihilist someone out there could be uh
pessimistic about where we're headed
there are bad people out there but these
are the stories that give you hope and I
hope people for one go see this movie
right now well as soon as possible bring
your friends and family but I hope
people are moved by the point where they
in some way get involved the message at
the end of the film from Jim
and I'm from you guys about this could
maybe inspire people the way Uncle Tom's
Cabin did I love it this this uh the
issue of trafficking often comes up uh
in the film nefarious have you guys seen
nefarious yeah
very good more of like a talking piece
but there's an excellent line spoiler
alerts it's been out for a little while
where you know this guy this this
psychiatrist thinks he's this virtuous
dude and then the demon says there are
more people in slavery today than when
slavery was legal and then he says I
don't know how many a large portion or
like more of that most of them are sex
slaves and and you sit here thinking
that you're doing good that that humans
have improved and that's the kind of
stuff where I'm just like
we need to stop we need to figure out
how we put an end to this and it's only
going to happen if people are moved to
believe in something
I often talk about why there's crime we
talk about Rising crime in cities and I
say it's not the laws necessarily it's
our it's our moral it's our cultures
it's our moral framework if people who
live in these cities don't care if
they're going to stand by and just watch
the crimes happen if the police aren't
going to intervene to arrest people if
laws are actually being put in place or
precedent that stops people from saving
the day you will continue to see this
stuff to grave but if more and more
people hold in their hearts that certain
things should not be there Unthinkable
and we will do something to stop it it
becomes normal
and then you stop it there will always
be evil but I think we've for the
longest time at least in my life so much
of what we've seen in in big cities
especially with the rising crime is
not my problem leave me out of it
I hope this film has the the effect of
making people not feel that way and say
we're going to be active we're going to
do something it's happening it's
happening I mean I have never seen in my
life so many people that they go they go
to seasonal freedom and when they leave
the theater
they videotape themselves and they share
their testimony with tears crying their
hearts are speaking and then they share
that with all their you know their
followers
those are our posters because we don't
have a budget for posters but we have
millions of people talking about this
film and that's the movement no one can
stop this movement anymore they can they
can stop team they can stop me they can
stop millions of people that are just
watching the film and it's gonna be just
more and more this is a global movement
brother this is just the beginning it's
always going coming out all over the
world and we're providing an opportunity
right now so something interesting
happened at the end of the film it used
to say and then they created operation
Underground Railroad
um and again I also became the CEO of
the Nazarene fund uh I told Angel
Studios take take the logo off of who
you are that's my baby I made it take it
off because so many organizations out
there are doing such great work and
we're not the solution to every kid for
many we are neither is it as rainfund
um and so uh I actually before the film
came out I stepped down from both
um so that I could create something
brand new it's the only scalable
approach and it supports Nazarene and
oer it's called the spear fund is I'm
actually announcing it for the first
time right now on your show the spear
from tip of the spear
um and what it is it's a scalable
approach to have to to ending this
because every kid deserves the best
rescuer the best rescue organization the
best Group whatever it is and and it's
not just one organization so what we're
doing is is me and I'm like the
co-founder of it is Jessica Munoz who's
one of the most uh
significant after Care Specialists in
the United States she built something in
Hawaii that was amazing called Pearl
Haven and we are we are getting funds
together so that we can then identify
it's a capitalistic kind of approach
where it's like if you're the best
you're getting you're getting the
funding
because you're the best option for that
kid and you're the best option for that
kid every kid's gonna get the best
rescue so if if if people can support
that's the
spearfund.org go there it's the it's the
fastest approach the most effective
approach to to rescuing kids and we're
super excited to to get people turned on
to that in the movie your your character
will you needed funding so is this like
you're now the the one that's funding
correct my undercover days are done okay
but oh you are we're we were one of the
first there's been many others but to do
what we do and the way we do it but
that's changed in the last 10 years lots
of like vet groups and the former law
enforcement guys have built these
amazing organizations so my goal now
have I've left the two organizations
that I that I love and I still love and
I will still support so that I can
support all the others because that's
what the kids deserve I mean if I'm
being again if I'm being honest
I'm not going to say that the one I
built is the end-all for everybody
and so but there is an end-all for that
one or that one and I want them all to
rise with the energy of this film I want
there to be a solution and if people
want to get involved the spearfund.org
give us what you can resources that way
and you'll watch we'll probably turn
stories and we'll introduce you to to
people who are rescuing kids you know
better than I can do it you know and and
uh and so it's it's exciting it's
exciting time because I think we can see
we can maybe end this thing you know is
it like oh no God but that that it's
because I imagine there's multiple tiers
of reasoning that why it's happening
it's like a financial reason for the
people in the very at the very top and
then it's like a sexual reason for the
the depraved that are purchasing into it
but like how do you disincentivize the
financial aspect you just make them
terrified that everyone around them is
going to turn them in next exactly you
gotta it's the deterrent effect that we
saw in Colombia you've got there's got
to be these guys have been working with
impunity throughout the world they're
rescue they're they're abusing children
selling them and there's no consequence
now other is and this movie proves I
hope every pedophile trafficker is
scared out of their mind right now
because they know that it's not just who
you are it's not just the Nazarene fund
but it's going to be every other group
that's going to be empowered now through
this film through the spirit fund and I
want them to be looking over their
shoulders and thinking twice before they
put their hand on a kid why do you think
it is so many media Outlets were uh
attacking the film insulting it saying Q
Anon or paranoid well first I'll say
this it's so bizarre because this film
was made produced written five six years
ago before Q Anon was even a thing so
it's impossible what they're saying why
are they saying it now here's my theory
I think I'm right there's an agenda out
there and there's a conversation to be
had and these Outlets don't want to have
it by the way the guardian Rolling Stone
they all praised this operation when it
happened they don't remember it was
eight years ago but I have the Articles
look at these guys rescue these kids in
Colombia and now eight years later oh
it's Q not it didn't even happen blah
blah there's a conversation they don't
want to have they don't want to talk
about the fact that there's 85 000
unaccompanied minors who came to our
border and were released and lost in the
in a country that's the highest consumer
for child sex material that's scary they
don't want to talk about the fact that
teachers unions are providing what we
would call pornography to third graders
right I used to be able to arrest people
for providing the material to children
that teachers are currently giving to
kids under the guise of sex education
they don't want to talk about 13 year
old girls being able to consent and I'm
very libertarian when it comes to all
these things for an adult right go get
the books yeah I think I got a couple of
books to talk about we have a book that
they've get that they have in great oh I
know that one yes that teaches children
how to use adult sex apps yes I'm very
familiar I just posted on this there was
a teacher who gave middle schoolers 10
to 12 years old a book called this book
is titled the book and in it it explains
how to use Grindr
182. yeah yes now that one you
I could have arrested people for giving
this to kids back in the early 2000s as
it should be and now teachers are giving
it to kids they don't want to talk about
this and then you know what it leads to
consent pedophiles have been pushing
consent consent kids should be able to
consent they should I've studied
pedophiles I've hunted them for two
decades right and they have platforms
they have literature kids should be able
to make decisions for voting for
whatever they want why are they saying
this well because they want them to have
legal consent to have sex with a 12 year
old 11 year old whatever you know what
this whole trans voice and again I'm
libertarian for adults do what you want
to do I will fight for your right to
choose to do that I don't but these are
children and when you let a kid consent
to gender mutilation or consent to
puberty blockers you're just you're an
inch away from allowing them to consent
to you've lost the argument but this
this quite literally is one of their big
arguments there have been uh numerous uh
writers in what they call the queer
movement who have talked about children
consenting there are prominent activists
who are making this argument and in fact
tomorrow we're actually going to be
having a debate about uh I'll keep it
vague for a little bit because I you
know I don't want to spoil it or or you
know scan the people who are coming on
the show but there's gonna be a
conversation about what is isn't
appropriate for kids yeah
I think it's fairly obvious
when we ask the question
we you know we have people come on uh
and and debate various ideas
and I and I'll and I'll show these books
to people and say for what reason should
children be shown these books and they
just blindly defend it
I I just want to say the real question
is not why do kids need to see this it's
why do you need to show this to a child
why are you so obsessed with ensuring
that a child will have their innocence
destroyed by this perverse content let
me ask you I mean you're the expert can
you break down how would you describe
grooming oh absolutely first
the pedophiles want a kid who's
sexualized who will participate and
choose to have sex with them that's what
they want but you got to get a kid's
sexualized first you know what porn does
to an adult brain I mean I've talked to
porn addicts an adult brain it changes
the chemistry of the brain it actually
creates a damage of the brain kids whose
brains are just like crystallizing still
they're little sponges so you give you
give a third grader this and they're
giving third graders this stuff and then
you expose them to tick tock and let
them have the I mean you these kids by
the time they're 13 they're sex robots
they all they know they're teaching kids
to masturbate doing some schools yes
that's part of it go to your official
corner and touch yourself while you look
at this so these kids are already
sexualized to the point where and again
pedophiles are salivating like hey
they're doing our job for us these
groups the the the the leftists out
there they're doing our job yeah for us
they're laughing They're laughing right
now
they are doing the job for us why not
they are doing the job the the groups
are wanting the same I mean you're right
the the I I made this argument there was
um
I can remember exactly what the story
was but I I was critical of literal
grooming in fact let's go back to uh
pre-elon musk Twitter
there was an image of adult men showing
graphic adult images to children and I
said this is grooming I got suspended
they deleted the tweet and they they
said you can't post this kind of stuff
and I'm like
I can't call out the abuse they said it
was offensive it was hate speech wow so
wow I criticize a story and I get these
leftist Publications
attacking me for it my response was if
my position is that child abusers are
bad and you rush to their defense and
attack me over it my only assumption is
you're a child abuser or you are in
support of child abuse both are wrong
yeah they get so angry about it but I'm
like there's no legitimate reason
to defend what they're doing in these
schools and for the same reason no
legitimate reason to attack sound of
Freedom that's the same motive and these
guys also every one of the most of these
Publications by the way you're going to
find they're also promoting this stop
calling them pedophiles that's mean call
them minor attractive persons and add
them to the lgbtq I will absolutely not
make it worse do you think that I've
heard yesterday I think you mentioned
the average age of a child that sees
pornography on the Internet is seven
years old
by some statistics and also five
thousand percent increase in child
trafficking are they somehow related is
this absolutely The Grooming absolutely
because they want willing victims they
want willing victims let me let me let
me ask you something about we've been
talking about this uh for the past
couple weeks
if someone goes out into public holding
up a graphic image of adults in engaging
in adult activities that person gets
arrested no question cop comes and
arrest them
the internet is a publicly accessible
space in much the same way
but for some reason we have not enforced
laws it's preventing people from posting
obscene lewd lascivious images in places
children have access to
why what's the difference now I know
there's a lot of Libertarians who are
like oh you're talking dangerous talk to
him we gotta have freedom here and I'm
like we don't have the freedom to go and
put up and take it take an advertising
truck with a TV on it park at the middle
of Times Square and play porn you can't
do that no they will come until that
vehicle to arrest you on the spot so how
is it that you can go on a social media
platform children use
and do the exact same thing
that's that's a question I have perhaps
I don't have the moral Authority or the
understanding to say what we should or
shouldn't do I lean towards maybe we
should make that we should enforce it as
illegal as it should be I'm wondering if
you would agree or what your thoughts
would be on that I mean I I do it it's
this weird double standard I'd say the
same thing if you see what kids are
doing if you're gonna talk about this
tomorrow on your show but what adults
are doing to kids in these in these
forms and these parades they're doing or
the or the you know the drag queen shows
I mean you've seen the videos they're
exposing themselves if that same person
walked to a school playground did that
same thing they'd be arrested but again
what's the they're still kids they're
kids in both places
um and here we are again and and there
are states I think uh I think Tennessee
who are trying to do create laws that
protect kids from that material that you
can't just post whatever there's there's
certain barriers there's there's ID
requirements that have to be verified
for a kid to get through a certain you
know a wall in in the internet I'm I'm I
think that's important to protect kids
yeah one thing
um I want to mention here you were sort
of talking about genderqueer and a lot
of this perverse literature that they're
putting into the school system one thing
that a lot of people aren't aware of is
that this isn't something on the fringes
and even what you were talking about
with respect to the pedophile who's
depicted at the beginning of sound of
Freedom who has written about how he
thinks these are natural impulses in
society's puritanical this person
unfortunately is part of a movement
which is much broader and more
mainstream Than People realize Alfred
Kinsey Wardell Pomeroy all the premier
sex researchers who we are told to look
to as experts and Pioneers said similar
things Kinsey wrote in his book sexual
behavior in the human female that the
reason a girl is traumatized when she's
abused when she's underage is because
the parents made a big deal out of it
and not because of what actually
happened this is in his published work
this is the person who's credited as
being the first person to scientifically
study sex his first book sexual behavior
in the human male was published in 1948
and sold several hundred thousand copy
this is a textbook people were reading
it and there was a table infamously
titled table 34 that includes data
tables which only could have been
collected through the abuse of children
I'm not going to graphically explain
what those data tables purport to
measure but it's hundreds and hundreds
of boys under the age of 15 who had to
have been raped for him to get that
information this is mainstream it's
public knowledge his co-author author
Wardell Pomeroy was in Time magazine in
the 1980s saying out loud that he thinks
incest between adults and children can
be in his words beneficial this is not
even hiding under the rug there's an
interview on the Phil Donahue show with
people from the Kinsey Institute in
Judith reason and they're defending all
of this saying that it was okay so these
aren't Fringe weirdos here and there
this stuff is way more mainstream Than
People realize it is it's just taking
this long but he's the father by the way
not only of our sex modern sex education
programs like this stuff he's also the
father of the pedophile movement yeah it
all dry from the same sick you know
backwards falsehoods yeah so thank you
for that I mean you you clearly know
yourself
you're talking about this uh this
pedophile at the beginning of the film
and also a real guy that you studied who
made that claim that all men have these
predilections or whatever and he thinks
everyone steals it's it's exactly like
it's the projection it's the world must
be the way I see it everyone must see
the world the way I do there's no other
explanation certainly
you know I'll put it this way I don't
think I was ever accused these people of
being smart something's clearly wrong
with them but
it's like my dude every country on the
planet is it to varying degrees wants to
stop you
right the United States is actively in
the process of trying to stop you
clearly the world thinks what you are
doing is wrong to believe otherwise is
insanity these people but as I said you
know I I don't know I wouldn't accuse
people of being smart even even Epstein
was not smart enough right right I gotta
know man like after having experienced
the last 20 years and making the movie
and everything how do you do you have
kids too if you I don't know if you want
to talk about it or not or but like how
do you educate your children about
sexuality now do they need to be
educated younger do they just need the
words to understand the body parts so
that if something they see something
they can tell you
um I mean I the idea of like saying no
go away I just don't I don't know that
that can ever work but let me let me
elaborate a little bit on that is you
know if there's a kid who doesn't
understand what's happening to them and
they can't articulate it how do you
navigate that that problem right
so I I my wife's in charge of that I try
to support but what she does and this
this requires actual parenting to do
this you have to know your kids
intuitively and and moms have a gift my
wife certainly does the gifts I wish I
had but I don't and so it's interesting
each of my kids have the conversation at
a different age some it's seven some
it's ten some wasn't they weren't ready
until they're 12 or 13. my wife
literally prays over when it's time to
say what and what to say and what
details to give also listen to your kids
ask questions so you've got to give them
the basics a certain point right like
you said they have to have the
vocabulary to be able to understand
where dangers come in but the kids will
ask and and satisfy their curiosity
otherwise the playground will and you
don't want the playground to satisfy
their curiosity so Catherine listens
okay you're going somewhere you have a
sit down I will be the one that gives
you the answer before somebody else does
so did you give them internet access
when they were younger it's the same uh
same process as some of my kids were
ready at 10 to begin monitored some not
till they're 13. it depends on it for
you it depends each it's customized you
know it's got to be monitored because I
want people I don't know where this this
culture came from this idea of like the
kid can go online have fun you're
basically saying you are giving your kid
a private jet to go anywhere in the
world and see whatever they want clearly
you would never allow that you're not
going to let your kid go down to the you
know you can't you you can't go north of
this street you can't go four blocks out
we tell our kids you know when I'm
growing up it's like don't go past this
street don't go past the street and we'd
listen for the most I come home when the
lights come on there were limitations on
how far we could go if you went too far
and you got lost you got kidnapped
something bad happened to you how your
parents gonna find out the internet may
not be the exact same thing in terms of
physical space but you can access
literally anything
that's ridiculous to allow a kid to do
whatever you imagine if you were like
you're allowed to go wherever you want
son even the adult bookstore down the
street go go no way and not only that
they wouldn't let you in it would be
it's illegal but the internet is
different they let kids do whatever they
want they don't think about it parents
really need to understand
it's not just quote unquote the Internet
it's unrestrained access to some of the
worst and the best things Humanity has
created not every kid is ready for all
that yeah I mean kids I I would say
there's a large quantity of things on
the internet no one could handle seeing
yeah let alone children with one click
yeah well there's there's videos of
murder yeah they're they're I remember
back in the day there was a viral video
of three guys murdering someone that was
going around and if you were just some
kid and your parents gave you a phone or
a computer you saw a graphic and brutal
murder take place that the children
should not be watching that stuff well
you made this point about the fact that
you wouldn't be allowed in an adult
bookstore if you were just walking down
the street or a place that sells
pornography I shouldn't use and that's
the missiles and not only that but
PornHub band access in the state of Utah
because Utah passed a law saying we need
to have stricter methods of verifying
people's ages so that kids don't end up
viewing porn on this website that made
PornHub very upset so not only is it the
case that kids are allowed into these
like digital establishments the
companies actually throw a fit when they
aren't
um and I'll also mention this
my dad made this point when I was a kid
and he was referring to television I
think it's even more pressing with the
internet today but he said this is the
first time in human history where
parents allow complete strangers into
their home to teach their children and
now uh it's it's two-way you know your
kid has an exchange with them the uh the
Trevor Project posted this interface
that they were advertising to talk to uh
somebody about your sexual identity and
if you hit the escape button three times
it deletes all of your browser history
and they were advertising that wow
they're advertising that so if an adult
walks in the room hit Escape three times
all of it's cleared now what would you
say about an adult who goes to a kid
tries to talk to him about sex and says
don't tell your parents horrifying it's
like textbook absolutely it's horrifying
it's grooming and it's part of again the
pedophile movement they've been saying
it for years get separate kids from the
parents they have namblin you know the
North American man boy love Association
other organizations in Europe that I've
hunted they have literature that teach
the pedophile how to separate parents
from kids how to get them alone how to
or how to even groom the parent to
become friendly with them so I mean
these are these are these are these are
pedo tactics so so we didn't actually
get into it and I see someone in some we
got a Super Chat someone uh was asking
uh Mike Spencer
why did it take so long for this film to
come out I mean you said you started
making what eight years ago eight years
ago the five team on Earth you have five
years to get it released after that well
actually it was it was three years of of
writing the script it was two years of
pre-production production and
post-production so I finished the film
three years ago and at that time was
owned by Fox Fox Latin America but then
Disney bought Fox so now the film was
owned by Disney so I negotiated with him
after they told me this is not for us so
it took us a year for rescue the rights
of the film after I had the rights back
I knocked you know the doors of Netflix
and Amazon and many others and they were
not interested they said this is not for
us this is not for us this is not for us
so for three years uh until I was again
you have two options you give up you
don't give up
next thing you know it was like teamwork
I mean should we put this on YouTube for
free or I mean we need to save children
but we want to raise awareness I mean I
was about to call my investors like hey
you know we did everything but it seems
like someone doesn't want this movie to
be in theaters and uh and it's it's done
like yeah business has it they're like
the movie's done and they go no we don't
wanna we don't want to go yeah they so
actually I went to Argentina because the
new headquarters of uh Disney Latin
America we're in Argentina so I went
there very nice people because when I
said when I I want to make something
very clear when I say that Disney is is
trying to corrupt your children I'm
talking about the cupola the elite you
know the the people who are very very
high level there's a lot of good people
working in Disney they just you know
they have no other options and and and
so I met very good people in Argentina
and they saw the movie they told me well
we need to have a meeting I'll get back
to you so I went back to Mexico like a
week later they they told me you know
this is not for us this is not for
Disney okay well give it back to me yeah
but you owe you owe money to uh to us
right now I know but you you promised me
well not you but Fox promised me that
they were going to do a documentary and
a TV series well we're not gonna do that
okay well then let's negotiate so one
year negotiating until finally a lot of
things happen but you know okay well
here's your movie so when I got the
movie back I was like okay so team what
should what should we do you know well
Netflix okay go let's go to Netflix how
do I send like this 100 messages I know
people that they know the the CEO of
Netflix and everything and they try and
they try and they try and nothing
nothing until I just you know what I
don't want to force something maybe God
has a different plan and he he did and
uh so what I did in Mexico at that time
because Alejandro was calling me and he
was Alejandro Monteverde my business
partner the director of the film he said
Eduardo the kids cannot wait any longer
we need to do something we cannot wait
until this revision happened and that's
when I had this idea of why don't we do
a tour in Mexico
where we invite every governor of its of
each state to host a screening to invite
all the leaders from every single sector
of our society in each state and then we
show the movie 2 000 people and then at
the end we sign an agreement where we
commit to Angel traffic in that state
and we did like 20 States and I was
about to finish the other 12 States when
I received the phone call from Angel
Studios and here and here we are you
know again I'm leaving
we're living this beautiful dream man I
mean I'm just we're broken souls and and
when you the feeling of knowing that
you're being used by God
to save children
I mean I've been crying every day
brother I feel like it's more than that
we've seen uh you mentioned Disney uh I
boycotted Disney a long time ago I ca I
so you know I I approached when Disney
plus comes out I buy the year plan and
then I think it was when Mulan came out
they thanked the security forces who are
holding uyghur Muslims and concentration
camps and people are Furious about I
mean the stories are coming out of there
horrifying I said I'm not gonna I'm done
with Disney plus I'm not gonna sign back
up for it I haven't I'm not going to
I think it's more than just saving kids
that's the immediate but the but also
understand the the cultural
ramifications of a successful film to
this degree
who do you think got fired at Disney
somebody turned this film down and now
someone's saying 54 million dollars in
10 days you know what what did we do
actually you know what what happened I
just got a phone call today and someone
told me hey do you read this article
where Disney is denying that they used
to own the rights of the of the film so
I have the contract I mean I have two
contracts actually uh signed by them so
should I put that on my Twitter I said
well we should so I'm gonna put that
because now they're lying you imagine
they're the nine that they used to own
this film but they don't want to look
you know they're humiliated because can
you imagine we're this is like the
Goliath David and Goliath right we're
like we're the little David here
fighting this big monster who is
corrupting your children son of Freedom
was wants to save your children and then
all the only message we we gave to the
people thing got thing things we took
out for the media who are supporting us
like you guys
this is what we said a in order for B
David in order for us to be David we
need you so if we all come together as
one voice we can be that David that
would defeat Goliath
um if we if that happens we know the end
of the story so we defeated Goliath at
least on July 4th and you know what
happened normally when you the first
week of the film let's say you have two
thousand years right
the second week you go to 1 500 theaters
and then 500 theaters and then you die
right yep so this is the opposite
the second week we have 400 Theaters
more and I just heard that we have three
more hundred theaters so this thing is
growing and growing because of the
people are and you know why too the
people are very generous when they go to
angel.com freedom angel.com freedom
people can buy tickets for themselves
for the family but they can buy through
pay pay it forward to other people other
families that they cannot afford to go
to bring their family to the theaters
and because of their generosity
these other people can see the film for
free that is changing the entire you
know I mean we're we're breaking the
establishment brother I just I hope that
there's some executive or some like
mid-level guy who is live we don't want
to do this film get it out of here and
now he's got a boss yelling at him like
we just lost 54 million dollars sorry
because you didn't the film was done it
was sitting right here five years
angel.com Freedom yes I'm gonna I'm
gonna pay a thousand bucks for this this
is the funny thing too God bless you man
the media says that uh it's a
faith-based film or whatever a
conservative and I'm like I don't
understand I I used to watch Law and
Order SVU all the time I'm like this is
just like if you took if you made a
movie that was like in a similar fashion
they say you know crime sexual crimes
are considered especially heinous Law
and Order that shows on there for for
decades people love it this film
it's it's like in the same genre it's
it's a it's it's drama Thriller crime
Life is Beautiful can you imagine saying
life is beautiful it's a Jewish Film no
you never say that oh Schindler's List
one of my favorite films you know
especially when when he when he talks
about this list is live
this is the same thing sound of freedom
is life but Angel Studios had a trailer
in the beginning of the movie that was
like a sci-fi movie I'm like good I want
Angel Studios to succeed I want them to
make more films they're not overtly like
it's not like you're like every movie is
in some way
got this through line of religion or
anything it's for everyone it's viral
story it's a true story I mean you know
what I like though it's like the
subtlety of the light versus the
subtlety of the dark Hollywood has a
subtlety of darkness and a lot of what
they do weird creepy things you might
notice in the background that are you
don't want your kids to know you don't
want your kids to to watch or ask
questions about you know they've got in
um uh I think it was Blues Clues there
was a beaver with mastectomy scars
and now now by all means if you want to
talk about cancer survivors and how they
have mastectomies we get that right
we're we're we're compassionate but to
show
a beaver in this way we know it wasn't
about cancer survivor because they'd be
wearing a shirt yes it was about giving
these gender ideology ideas to little
kids without you noticing that's the
subtlety of Darkness Angel Studios can
make a sci-fi film that's not overly
religious or whatever thing but then
there's subtlety of light in those films
so if all they're doing is making movies
is entertaining we're winning I said
this about the daily why or why I'm
excited to see them succeed they make a
movie that's a western
it's not a conservative film it's just a
film I'm like that's what needs to
happen because if the bare minimum of
what we do is we end the weird subtlety
of darkness and and this and this
erosion yeah and we just course correct
and start working towards things that
inspire people to be more virtuous or
moral
yeah you said the word inspired media
influence how people think you know
what's the average percentage between
parents and children having meaningful
conversations every day in America and I
think now it's in the whole world three
to six minutes a day but in front of the
media social media movies videos radio
whatever more than 10 hours a day so who
is educating their children it's not
parents neither schools it's the media
so media I mean is good or bad whatever
it's just it's just a mean you know how
you use it is what changed everything
right so heart has the power to change
people's hearts Plato said if you have
to choose between art or politics to
govern a nation he said I would choose
art because art has the power to touch
people's hearts and change their minds
therefore how they think how they live
how they behave so this is powerful you
know media influence how people think
and young people they have this tendency
to imitate art when they go and see the
movie they imitate what they see so can
you imagine if we just lead by example
that's why Tim Ballard in the movie
jinkaviso he speaks very needle
everything's just actions actions
actions because action speaks thousand
words right and our hope is that when
people see this movie sound of Freedom
they will live not only entertain but
they will even Inspire wanting to love
more wanting to forgive more wanting to
become the best version of yourself the
best version of yourself wanting to
become more like Tim Ballard you know
this is a true heroes this is not like
Superman or Spider-Man you know what
this is about a true hero and we all can
become Heroes we are called to be heroes
actually and my goal as a filmmaker is
is that when people leave the theater
they will love to become ambassadors of
freedom and I hope they will ask the
same question I asked myself eight years
ago what can I do to end this I want to
join the Army I want to join the Army
and I think we have an army of more than
five million people now in America this
is amazing you know right I do hope I
hope you guys get
50 million dollar penthouses with
infinity pools a couple uh Corvettes
some Ferraris some Lamborghinis I hope
you know why
and I genuinely mean this
who deserves luxury more than those who
are doing good to benefit the world is
it the celebrity or the music you know
no I've I've always thought when I was
younger like why is it that a
firefighter gets paid a lower salary but
a baseball player is a multi-millionaire
and so of course there's a I'm being a
bit facetious and I don't really expect
you guys to buy those things but I hope
that the younger generation sees success
of this movie The millions of dollars
they see the movement and they think the
paths to the path to success is being a
good moral person who fights for the
betterment of the world and I want there
to be I want Tim Ballard to roll up in a
nice car with a nice suit and the kids
to be like how do I be like him it's
like oh you save children's lives
instead what do we get we get
you know be hard be streets be a
celebrity make songs about looting
lascivious behaviors we got we gotta
switch that around yeah you know Ben
Shapiro famously rapping you know that
song whap yeah we'll get into it yeah
how do we we Sam Smith doing the satanic
dances how do we shift that to the guy
walking on stage with a nice suit and
the gold chains is the guy who saves
children for a living well you know one
thank you for for that but at the same
time I just want to you know you may
agree with me you may not agree with me
but I have to say it and that's how I
feel
you know Mother Teresa said we are not
called to be successful we are called to
be faithful to God that is our success
now if by being faithful to God by being
faithful to our values success come it's
a blessing thanks be to God let's use
that success to make a difference in
people's lives because you know what
we're going to die one day
life is too sure brother and we're
taking nothing nothing does except for
our actions nothing's wrong with success
as long as you don't compromise your
values but if success doesn't come after
being faithful never compromised never
compromy is not worth it exact Beauty
does not come from outward adornment we
have a big advantage in uh in this
culture war and that is
I think a higher degree of selflessness
the left has collectivism they fall in
line they March in lockstep
but if a movie like this and the profits
from it go towards the mission and
expanding that mission that's something
they don't have exactly these people
many of these left is our virtue
signalers they'll say whatever they have
to say just to make money for themselves
they can buy themselves a mansion
if the money generated from people
seeing this movie
doesn't go towards Lamborghinis and
infinity pools and it in fact goes
towards making more culture building
making more movies inspiring more people
to do better
that that passion and that drive and
that mission is something they don't
have because this is a mission exactly
what you just said this is not just this
is a movement this is a mission this is
a vision this is like our I mean we made
a promise that we would dedicate our
entire life to Angel trafficking and
this is not going to be you know ended
with one movie this is just the
beginning you know when the movie starts
brother
the movie starts
for the people when the movie finished
that's the beginning of the movement
with the film finished that's how I felt
when I saw it like I was like a
different person I was it was hard to
watch kind of I was like breaking apart
and then I was rebuilt at the end
I really want to thank Jim Caviezel man
oh brother yeah amazing I wanted to talk
about him for a second because I mean he
deserved that you said earlier he didn't
have a lot of lines and I noticed that
and it was his eyes man you can see his
brain the eyes are connected to the
brain and you see it like I don't know
did you spend a lot of time with him
yeah we did we're super good friends and
he spent he spent time with me and and
Alejandro said something in the
beginning he says whoever plays this
role has to say way more with his eyes
than he does with his mouth that was
before Jim even agreed and that's
exactly what caviso pulls off that was
something his idea this crazy team
mother because I was thinking about
someone else you know someone like looks
like him younger and everything and when
I asked him hey brother 20 people pass
so who who do you want to play you and
he looked at me and he said Jesus Christ
Brother come on I'm not kidding he's too
expensive you know no I'm talking about
the guy who played Jesus Christ in in
The Passion of Christ of Mel Gibson oh
man I thought for a second you went
crazy and you know him yeah I know him
but why him because he has the you know
he's Brave he's a Godly Man and I know
he's going to be an actor who is not
going to be coming here you know play
the role go to the go to the premiere
and then next movie he will stay with us
until the end right so I text him I say
brother I have something for you when
can I see you in two hours in this
coffee so Alejandro and I went to meet
with him we pitched the story to him and
he starts crying he said brother this is
too personal to me and he shared a very
personal story and I was like wow okay
this is this is your story brother this
is I mean this is it so the next day he
calls me and he tells me I have a good
news and a challenge
what is the what is the good news I mean
that's it tell Tim Ballard tell
Alejandro that I mean what is the bad
news what is the challenge well you know
my my wife so narcos Colombia on Netflix
and she's afraid for me to go to
Colombia to film this movie
oh man I hated that because you know
again media influence how people think
Latinos we have been stereotyped in a
very negative way since the photos until
today and then a lot of people here in
this country they think Latinos we are a
threat to the Democracy of this country
because they think that we are what what
they see in film or television all the
negative stereotypes so and and this TV
series they do a lot of damage and here
you have this uh Jenkins wife saying
he's not going to Colombia I said well
hold on a second let me just call Tim
butter I'll call you right back team I
have a good news and a bad news brother
good news obviously seeing bad news
his wife saw narcos Colombia on Netflix
and she doesn't want him to go there
what can we do and he's thinking and
thinking he said tell them if they
action Navy Seals 30 x Navy Seals will
be enough to protect him I called him I
pass a message green light we're in
Columbia right but look what happened 30
of these guys who were on set a week
later half of them are not on set
anymore
and I'm like okay I'm not going to say
anything as a producer I know who is on
set we have 200 people extras actors
whatever you know and I noticed that
half of them were not there so
one month and a half later I'm reading
this local newspaper from Colombia that
it says that the federal police arrested
some traffickers and rescued more than
200 children in Cartagena Colombia who
were kidnapped for sex reputation and
and more details like in the movie very
similar story to the movie so I run to
see Tim Ballard and I said brother look
like in the movie and he smiled he said
that was us what that was us half of the
guys who were not on set they were
walking on the Cartagena streets on
Saturday and these people came and
approached them hey amigo Gringo you
want Senoritas young ladies how many you
won they thought they were tourists
looking for Action right wow next thing
you know they didn't know that these
guys were experts on Rescue children
right so they they say well can I call
you tomorrow because there's more
Americans coming and we we we need more
girls do you have like really young
girls brother we have everything you
need okay we have chickens chickens
means like very little boys and girls
right so um anyway so they rescued these
children they started this undercover
operation with the help of the police
Columbia Police so I'm thinking like
yes I mean the second week brother of
filming half of these guys were rescuing
200 children and I'm thinking wait a
second
thank God forging caviso's wife who said
no in the beginning because of that no
he was inspired Tim butter to bring
Teddy ex-nabis seals and because of
those Statics Navy Seals half of them
rescued 200 children before before the
film was even finished sound of Freedom
too can you imagine I mean this is
brother I'm just there's so many
miracles we say I remember saying this
question because let's focus on this
theorem first you know I I mean I mean
here I'm crying I mean the story just
wrote itself that's amazing I'm telling
team brother even if this film
never see the light even if tomorrow
then there's an earthquake and the
entire film is berry right the fact that
we were used
to save 200 children it's all worth it
man I can die in peace never imagine
that eight years later five million
people are watching this film in America
come on I mean if this is not the
American dream for me for a Mexican
filmmaker who moved to this country 20
years ago without without speaking
English I'm huggling American dream I'm
so grateful to this nation for opening
the door to my dreams God bless this
wonderful Nation God Bless America God
bless Mexico let's make Mexico and
America free again
yeah let's we're gonna go to super chats
but you want to get one more does Jim's
wife know that she inspired though of
course man are you kidding me I mean she
saved 200 children just by that no by
her concern for her husband and later
she said yes and later 200 children are
free maybe the reason she had that
feeling that she needed people there
wasn't so much to protect Jim but
because something was calling her to
send in the troops worse that's how God
works we don't understand the beginning
why bad news whatever that bad news was
the best news ever
it seems it was a challenge stories like
this they seem impossible they seem like
Miracles but they happen let's read
super chats if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends and head over to
timcast.com become a member by clicking
join us we're gonna have a members only
segment if you guys have been a member
for at least six months you can submit
questions and potentially call into the
show to talk to us and ask questions and
of our guests and if you sign up right
now at least it's 25 per month level you
can immediately submit fast questions we
have to have this gate to keep out
nefarious actors who want to come in and
screw with us and then we have a
screening process
um and I do want to be honest at this
point many of the callers may have
already been chosen so I don't want to
you know get your hopes up if you've not
signed up yet but uh come and watch the
members only after show which will be up
in about 25 minutes but for now we'll
read your super chats
let's grab I want to try and find uh the
best super chats directly uh asking
questions of you guys so we can uh get
into that Spencer Jones says Tim I met
you a few years ago via Marisol Nichols
been donating to our ever since keep it
up God bless
not sure if you're uh if you know who
that is or well Marisol Nichols is one
of my best friends she's oh she's an
actress if you watch Riverdale no I know
of it yeah she's very successful actress
and she actually done undercover work
with us as an actor I mean undercover
operators are first and foremost actors
right and she's phenomenal she's rescued
dozens and dozens of kids using her
undercover skills so so thank you thanks
for mentioning Marisol and thanks for
your support Shadow's hand says I saw a
sound of Freedom earlier today thank you
Tim B for your continued efforts on that
front definitely a film everyone needs
to see how can one join your cause in
person in operation Underground Railroad
check out the website info our
rescue.org and send in your resume
and but you did step down are you still
involved in any way I'm still the
founder always the founder I'll always
support and send money and but uh I mean
oh the website name again oh you are
rescue.org but yeah I stepped down from
both the offended any official capacity
I just like I said I want to help
the whole cuts on all the organizations
so
let's grab some more Super chats I I'm
taking my time because I'm trying to
find good questions pretending the film
and uh Eric CK asked early on Tim Bowden
you're a true hero what do you know
about the human trafficking in Ukraine I
know we did mention it a little bit I
don't know if there's anything else to
elaborate on well I'll say this the docu
series called hidden War you can check
out the trailer actually online just
Google
DNA films
hidden War it's an amazing trailer uh
Mel Gibson's involved with that Tony
Robbins is a producer and you're going
to see a crazy story a four-part series
early next year hidden War check it out
all right uh what is it spoon stealing
Irishman says I'm under your house I'm
in your walls I cannot be stopped I will
not stop that's the problem spoons were
just the beginning soon I will take your
host chair and the end game will be in
motion do you see this my hands are
right here there's no way I could have
possibly generates me yeah no hold on a
second spoons like four days ago I have
been falsely accused of stealing spoons
from this man and hiding him under his
house it's nonsense listen you guys know
me you know I wouldn't do that oh I know
do something like that this is
ridiculous
I'm being maligned smeared by the
liberal press once again
let's grab some uh Super Chat saddle
effing says I've been donating
monthly since I heard of Tim ballad and
our seven years now Tim you are doing
the Lord's work one question
who does Tim walk around with those
massive steel anchors he has how does he
that's a good one
yeah
did you really infiltrate a Colombian
Rebel Camp okay so
um we did a podcast on this as well so
the um the original script had it where
we actually did go and it was a a camp
uh that was all sorts of kids slave sex
trafficking it looked very much like
that it was not in Colombia it was in
another place on the border between
Dominican Republic and Haiti we were we
were accosted with men with guns
gangsters and machetes I didn't go by
myself
and and you know you've never give me
problems some of your executive
producers like don't tell don't don't
ruin the illusion oh no no that's why we
say base in the true story I said I'll
always be honest always be honest raise
your story because again when you have
someone like him who does rescue
missions every two weeks
man and he's telling you like 100
stories it's and and the challenges that
you have two hours it's like brother
there's so many elements like I need to
bring elements of of every single Rescue
Mission so we can tell one story but uh
we in reality
it's it's
more dangerous what this guy is going
through if the movie I mean you could
sweet this is a poetry what we what
Alejandro wrote they said poetry with a
lot of light and and and darkness you
know fighting light and dark with the
music and everything the innocence and
the purity of the children the actors on
set were like these kids they never knew
what this film is about the parents were
there it was a family environment and uh
but except for the one little girl you
gotta tell that story yeah but that was
an accident brother I know you got to
tell that story well it's beautiful you
know the this is what happened so we
have the parents of the children's the
children on on this island and we have
like these two coaches they were like
the acting teachers right so Alejandro
was communicating with them and with
their parents to get the emotions but
that day
the two teachers you know they had to go
somewhere else so they sent a new
teacher and a new coach and Alejandro
didn't over that the director so next
thing you know we're doing a very
important scene which is you know the
scene where they close the curtains
I'm gonna say a lot you know because I
don't want to spoil this but anyway she
she's supposed to be uh crying because
before that scene she was abused
sexually abused by by an adult right
so then uh okay well let's let's film uh
so Alejandro talked to the coach so I
just want her to cry a little bit it's
going to be just five seconds ten
seconds and and that's it you know it's
gonna be very simple scene and that's it
okay right boom
we start filming
First Take Alejandro's like wow we have
it cut Alejandro's working to rehearse
for the next scene and he noticed that
she's still crying and she's just crying
it's like Alejandro called you know he
called the coach
why is she still crying
oh you told me that you needed like the
emotions yeah but this is like 30
minutes later she's still she's still
crying what happened
will I have to tell her that what
happened to her you know and what oh
what do you mean so she told her
that she was abused before she never
heard about these things ever in her
life well she cried for days we couldn't
fire that teacher only because we were
in this island where if we fire her we
don't have a coaching for the kids for
the next scenes right
but man we got very angry because that
that was the number one rule the
children cannot know what this film is
about because we cannot put touch in
their minds we need to protect their
innocence and their purity on set it's
like if my son is in a movie like this I
want to be with him I want to read the
script I want to talk to the direct to
the I want to talk to the director I
want to make sure that his innocence and
Purity is is intact right and and it was
just an accident here but that scene
when you see that scene when you see the
film again because when you watch this
film for the second time and the third
time is even better I have seen the film
like thousand times as a producer and I
cry like every single time and it speaks
to me in a different way but that scene
breaks my heart because I know I know
what happened there was one take and
that's what they used is that the main
act girl
she's amazing but when you when you
watch that scene again in the top go
back and see the movie again just for
that scene and you're realizing you're
seeing real emotion real real emotion of
a little girl who just found out
what she wasn't supposed to know of the
role she was actually playing
let's read this one Adolfo says Tim
Ballard what are your thoughts on the 85
000 kids missing from the USA USA
custody at the border do you believe
that a significant portion of those
children are being trafficked I
absolutely do I spent 10 years on that
border and with the cartels make 14
million dollars a day they take these
kids
um health and human services policy they
have to get the kids within like 24
hours once they're there 85
000 unaccompanied CBP tells us that
thousands of them were under five years
old
they what they do is they they deliver
them to Health and Human Services the
little kids come with a name sometimes
it's bought a safety pin to their shirts
or in their pockets and the name's the
sponsor George Smith for the phone
number they call that number hey we have
a little you know Jose Gonzalez here oh
yeah yeah send them to this address they
used to have to go pick them up and it's
easier it's easier to adopt a cat out of
a shelter than it is to come down and
take one of these kids out of out of the
custody of the US government but now
your taxpayer dollars will send the
child
by plane or bus
in what will likely be or many times at
least be the very last leg of a child
trafficking event because can you
imagine this imagine if a little child
was found in New York City or I don't
care where for you know DC Salt Lake
City that child would be treated like a
precious thing that it is that you're
not going to deliver that kid to any
person who shows up there'll be
background checks DNA tests documents
whole thing and yet we're not affording
the same thing to foreign kids they like
to call Trump like careless or doesn't
care about the foreign kids or whatever
well what are you doing you care nothing
about these kids to let them be released
without any kind of background check
just to whoever claims them and that's
the reality of what's going on and I'll
remind you the United States is the
number one consumer of child sex
material so it's not it's not a safe
place for kids to disappear my friend
Jorge Ventura give me this he was on the
border it says there you go I know
exactly what that is yeah this is number
4186 wrapped around a kid 's little
wrist unbelievable this is this is
slavery this is this is branding for
slavery to identify kids to count them
and keep track of them and you see the
exchange with Senator Cruz and and
secretary mayorkas where he Senator Cruz
brought these bracelets he says in
America says I've never I have no idea
what you're talking about wow I talked
to Cruz later about it he said I I was
shocked I thought for sure he was going
to know about it I was going to talk to
him about it he's like I don't even know
I don't know what that is this is this
the brand of slaver this is this is a
sign of slavery
and you know and I think that the fake
IDs too I think we have one of those
yeah do you know oh yeah like what time
is it right now for example 9.95 so what
time we started this this interview hey
so it's like almost two hours almost
yeah
um seven children disappeared in Mexico
right now in this interview every 20
minutes one more and then another one
and another one and another one 57 a day
twenty one thousand a year this is
official numbers from the government I
think that's that's a lot more
I read I read a story out of uh I think
it was Austin Texas it may have been
further south
and it was on Reddit some woman said
that she was at a bar with her boyfriend
and two of their friends they were all
drinking have a good time they got
pretty drunk and she's like I think she
said she was early 20s early 20s they
walk outside and she's I think what the
story was that she was texting on her
phone and her boyfriend and his two
friends were about 10 feet in front of
her laughing and you know joking and
stuff she's lagging behind when a car
pulls up they pop the dope and run out
grab her and try and pull her into the
car she screams her boyfriend and
Friends run back grab the door grab her
leg as the car tries speeding off and
they pull her out wow and apparently
there's tons of stories like this people
don't realize because they don't make
the Press well like in the movie we have
real footage real footage at the
beginning of the movie just like that
and it's it's it's it's really
horrifying man is it mostly just off the
street sorry to interrupt if you no I
just like one one of them is like kids
are playing outside a car pulls up
snatches a kid the other kids are just
like what do we do yeah that's crazy is
that is it like the majority of the
disappearances or kids just being
snatched off the street or is it
sometimes but you know what sometimes
they just do it in your own house you
know they they their innocence and their
purity are being stolen forever when
your kid is having a smartphone and
start talking to strangers to another
kid who is being kidnapped by someone
else and they use him as a hook to
connect with your child next thing you
know they start uh that happened to my
niece in Mexico the other day my cousin
calls me Eduardo your niece I mean I've
been following you and because of the
whole movement now I'm like more alert
as a parent you know and I I noticed
that she was acting weird you know my
daughter uh she's eight years old eight
years old and she happens to be for the
last six months she was she was talking
to this strangers and she was sharing
pictures of her of you know of her body
I mean
if she wouldn't cut her on time God
knows what what next what will happen
next you know meet me in the corner you
know so I mean the whole message of son
of freedom is for parents too you need
to pay attention to your children you
need to protect your children you know
just you need to watch what they're
watching you need to observe what
they're watching on the internet there's
apps out there where you can actually
see what they're looking at so you can
control them you need to be presents
because you know the other day even my
sister the eight years ago when she
noticed that uh that uh she told me
what's the next project and I said well
you know this is more about shelter I
don't want to know I don't want to know
I don't want to know I said Daniela if
if someone needs to know is you because
you have children and they are the
target you need to know the more
information the more prevention what do
you mean what do you mean and now it's
just like a lion like she's like
protecting her children she's a
volunteer she's an ambassador of Freedom
so parents they need to know that this
is real this is not in Bangladesh Island
you know far away this is next door this
is everywhere and it's growing because
of child pornography
you know there's a lot of new clients
because they get hooked with pornography
next thing you know they're looking at
child pornography now they're addicted
and now they want the real deal there's
interesting Beatrice Arena says they
have censored the movie in Colombia they
won't allow it to show have you heard
that uh no but we're going to show it
after the success in the United States
no one can stop this movement it's going
to be in Mexico August 31st and then the
rest of Latin America is going to be
everywhere no one can stop this
it's too late the movement is growing
Big Time Gigi Izzy asks was making it
PG-13 an intentional choice because I
absolutely love the fact that it's not
too explicit and that I can reach a
wider audience yeah of course that was
the whole goal we want everyone to watch
this movie
um the integrity and the purity of the
film is is right there so everyone can
see it and it can be digestible you know
the first part of the movie is the
problem the second part of the movie is
the solution and the Hope because we
want people live with hope yes tears
because this is real but with hope okay
I want to do something I want to join
the Army I will do something and I and
again as I said before I hope they will
ask themselves what can I do well the
first thing they need to do is just tell
everyone what you saw in the movie tell
more people to go and see the movie
because if the movie continue with the
success then the media secular media
mainstream media everybody is obligated
to talk about the success of the field
more important about the topic of the
film and then millions of people will
hear about this and then there's no more
excuses of oh I didn't know oh now you
know what are you gonna do about it do
you think that parents should bring
their kids if they're 13 and up or is
that just like a parent by parent well
that's a you know
13 up I think 13 13 up I think they
should because
you're not going to see anything that
you have to cover your eyes or you have
to cover
the eyes of your kid nothing I make
movies I made that promise to God one
day and I made a promise to my mother
and to my father 20 years ago when I
promised together I will never use my
talents to do anything that would offend
my faith my family or my Latino culture
after I made that promise I ended up not
working for four years and I just I lost
everything that's why I became a
producer because as an actor I was I was
tired of waiting for a role that would
portray a man as a real man so it was
led to open a production company so I
can have the power to control the
message and I told my mother you know I
met I'm gonna make a promise to you that
every film that Alejandro Monte Verde
and I will do you don't you don't have
to cover your eyes in anything
you can watch everything
and and I've been uh you know faithful
to that promise my first movie was Bella
then little boy now sound of freedom and
even this sound of Freedom movie as hard
as it is as heavy as it is it's a poetry
that everyone can see it and you don't
have to cover your eyes in anything
sweet potato night says will there be a
Blu-ray DVD sound of Freedom director's
cut extended edition eventually yes
because you know they when when copied
when when this landemia pandemic said in
English pandemic that movie no when the
carpet hit oh and covet yeah pandemic
pandemic yeah in Spanish we call it
plandemia it was planned anyway it's a
joke but um when
theaters were close right remember and
then when they opened the theaters was
only 20 yeah so we thought
forget about theaters let's talk about
you know uh platform release right so
the original cut was then two hours 35
minutes because you can launch movies
like that in platforms and you don't
have to like you know the one hour 45
minutes or two hours rule for theaters
so we have a car that is one hour I mean
two hours 35 minutes that is like a
meditation man it's a meditation and of
course we want to launch that later I
actually thought I wondered if you're
gonna have it for streaming like 10
bucks for it to download it from your
website but there was something special
about being in the theater Jim even
talked about it at the end of the movie
I mean like I I remember the the vision
of seeing the people in front of me as
we're talking about it I can feel them
you know why because you have to
understand
that's why movies are so so so amazing
and so important when you are watching a
movie in a theater this is a big room
with a big screen it's all dark no
distractions no cell phones no nothing
and for two hours you're gonna open your
heart and the director is going to tell
you something that's why it's so
dangerous though because when the
director is he wants to manipulate you
and give you the wrong message you can
have a huge impact in your life too and
then you leave confused but when you use
it for you know with truth
you change people's lives I mean you
inspire people that's that's my goal to
inspire people so they can leave the
theater Inspire like
I wanna I wanna become a hero and and
and that's the most beautiful thing when
you when you hear testimonies of people
like your movie changed my life you're
moving uh your movie inspired me to
protect my children I hug my children I
want to spend more time with them
it feels amazing brother
all right let's grab some more
let's see there's one we we did Mike
Spencer shout out we did ask about why
it took so long to make the movie but
that's your super chat so we do
appreciate it
atherin zala says the movie was great
and reminded me of proof of life I was
wondering if you were going uh if you
going into the jungle to uh near the end
of the film was true and do you think
that part might put doctors doing that
in any danger so uh we did we just
addressed this a little bit but I I was
thinking it'd be a good uh chance to
clarify the the camp you did go to first
I guess uh it was not in Colombia you
did go to a camp did you go to more than
one was this like a common thing you had
done we've we've that yeah that Tech has
been used a few uh enough times that we
won't use it again anyway
um
there's certain places on the planet
that you just can't you just like the
film depicts you know that you can't get
into but I didn't go alone you know I
had several people with me but we did
impose as that
um
yeah in terms of would that put doctors
at risk because what they think that
they go in there they think they might
be a
someone who's there to to do them harm
it's a good it's I mean of course it's
dangerous I mean what we're doing is
dangerous too I mean we don't have to go
to the Jungle what we're doing right now
just going into Mexico showing this
movie in 32 states
telling the people this is real and
we're going to end it it's dangerous
because when you are confronting when
you're fighting with this more than 150
billion dollar industry that's a it's
not the small thing right but you know
what yes it's dangerous but it's more
dangerous not to do it in the long term
and as I said before you we're gonna die
one day and you know what my prayer I my
prayer every day to God is okay when
when is my time when you knock at my
door and it's time to go uh please find
me working for you and I feel that we're
working for for God by Saving children
that's why I always say God's children
are not for sale and that's my
motivation every day to wake up and to
give my life or for a cause for a
mission for something that is bigger
than myself
Kim mccersey says it ain't much Timbo
but please if possible forward these
Super Chat funds to Tim Ballard's cause
thanks uh I'll one-up that I will I will
donate all of the chat Revenue to the uh
to the spear is that the spirit is the
best way to put it yeah and I'll put 10
000 towards the pay it forward for the
film God bless you so much when wrapping
up easy easy easy for me to do easy for
me to say it's not that you know I don't
like we can do it we're going to do it
let me tell you why this is so important
there's a lot of families that are
listening to interviews that they have
four children five five children they
cannot afford to bring everyone to the
experience because sound of freedom is
Cinematic experience right that you
cannot see that on TV or on on social
media film is different film change your
life right so because of your generosity
your generosity
thousands of people
we'll go and see the film for free
and we're saving lives right there
and the movement is growing and more
people in media are talking about the
success of the film so you put pressure
we're going to show the movie and on the
25th brother on the Capitol Hill can you
imagine that that's powerful because
you're going to have Congress from both
sides Republicans and Democrats right
they're going to see the film and then a
panel with Jim Tim and myself
can you imagine moving the hearts of the
most important decision makers in the
world who are living here in Washington
DC this is a huge opportunity you know
the only reason why they're doing that
is because of the success of the film
I mean we can change the world
if more people see this film we're
competing with Mission Impossible right
now and you know what as much as I like
Tom Cruise and Mission Impossible
that movie won't save lives
sound of freedom is changing the culture
is saving lives
and it's inspiring so many people to
become ambassadors of freedom so thank
you for your generosity and I hope a lot
of people that are listening to this
interview this podcast they go right now
when this interview finished to
angel.com freedom angel.com freedom and
pay it forward so somebody else can see
the movie for free because of your
generosity I should have said this at
the start of the show but uh I will
elaborate too so the way it works we
have this meter here on YouTube that
shows us the total amount of super chats
that came in during the show what
happens is YouTube takes 35 we get the
rest
forget the 35 the total number that's
there I'm going to donate to your uh to
your organization and then 10 000
towards the paid four for people to be
able to watch this movie to be able to
go see it and so uh now everyone's
dumping in the super chats and that was
the the intended position so basically
I'll cover that 35 cut that YouTube
takes to make sure the full amount of
the chat Revenue goes to your
organization we're currently at three
thousand six hundred dollars and uh
we're gonna we'll wrap up the show from
here because we're gonna go to the
members only portion of the show over at
timcast.com so as we're closing out if
you'd like to contribute the super chats
I will immediately as we're on the
members only I will be making that
contribution and the full amount of all
of our Super Chat Revenue plus the
donation to the movie because I I we you
know we've been talking about doing this
thing where we give ten thousand dollars
every month to someone engaged in a
cultural effort that's going to be a
positive impact I won't consider this
that we'll still try and find someone
that we can give you know who needs the
money to get their project going but I
will absolutely see to it that uh you
know we'll do that because um see you
guys you you're the guys you're you're
the movement you're changing uh culture
because we we did we did our part you
know we'll we made a movie but with
other people without you
we go nowhere so it's amazing how we're
coming together and I believe that
together we will end this nightmare
we'll bring freedom to the children that
are not free right now I just realized
the mistake with everything I was just
saying I I can't give the total amount
of super chats to your organization
because people could just do that on
their own they could literally just go
to the organization and make a donation
I'm gonna double it whatever you guys do
in Super chats by the end of the show
I'm gonna give I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna match it oh super chats are flying
in right I was just thinking I was like
why should I ask people to give me money
for my show and then just give it to you
and they could do that themselves I'll
match it one for one thank you so much
man now easy easy for me to do I know
look at these man those are the
ambassadors of Freedom right there
brother I'm gonna imagine 100 movement
that's you think they're going to stop
this movement who's gonna stop this
movement brother nobody nobody I I want
to say uh we gotta go to members only
and I want to say one final thing before
we do the outros and give people an
opportunity to send to the super chats I
will match them
the timateo scene in that film
it made me feel something indescribable
I call it divine intervention but it it
it's Indescribable that that moment
where you rescue a kid who gives you a
name tag with your own name on it
I I have no words for what but for me
it's it makes me believe that everything
we're doing is it has a purpose as a
reason we are here for something bigger
than us something better than us that
will make everything better that will
improve things that will lead us to uh
whatever whatever the plan is we are
instruments of it the work you guys have
done so
thank you so much for what you're doing
guys timcast.com become a member we have
that members only show coming up in a
minute but if you guys want to shout
anything out as we wrap up Tim
just just gratitude thank you guys so
much I can't believe that there's this
many people the silent majority as as
risen I never thought I never dreamed it
would happen but I have hope for the
first time I've hoped that we could
actually make an enormous impact in the
fight against child slavery
gratitude is how we felt and uh
you know I'm from Mexico I'm I'm
Catholic I believe in the power of
Prayer
I want to ask permission
can I say hail Mary for all the kids
around the world absolutely please
I mean Hail Mary full of grace the Lord
is with thee blessed are diamonds women
and blessed is the fruit of thy womb
Jesus holy Mary Mother of God pray for
us sinners now and at the outer dead
amen our lady Guadalupe pray for us
libertad
thank you thank you guys so much for
being here I'm your film's an
inspiration it was an amazing film I was
entertained I was moved this has been uh
uh amazing so thank you so much thank
you uh Sheamus do you want to shout out
you want to say anything as we do I mean
uh I want to shout out everything that
you guys are doing and uh Tim you've
been very humble in saying things like
oh the storytellers are the people
starting the movement and we're part of
this movement and I do believe there's
power uh in story but sir what you are
what you are doing and what you are
saying about yourself is it's such a a
massive understatement you have changed
so many lives and to go after just one
Lost Child is such a beautiful imitation
of Christ and I want to thank you for
that I want to thank you for being that
example uh in the world and I I want to
thank you for all of the work you're
doing and the work that you've done
thank you so much really appreciate that
of course people are going to follow you
guys on Twitter we got at Tim Ballard we
have at E badest I mean uh in in English
I'm sorry uh
let me spell that out it's
e-v-e-r-a-s-t-e-g-u-i
there you go
on a side note Tim someone told me that
you work with uh Tim Kennedy or have in
the past is that true have you ever
worked with Tim Kennedy before no
someone told me why well maybe you will
in the future I love that man he went
over to Afghanistan during the surrender
and was pulling people out uh over the
course of a week and uh just freaking
inspiration after inspiration
thank you guys so much oh thank you
let's make American Mexico free again
together we're stronger I would love uh
I fully agree and last thing of course
it's spearfund.org and uh our rescue.org
um all right let's move this along Serge
you've been the man tonight yeah I uh
Tim is calling you guys are destroying
the chat Revenue it's sweet that's great
to see I'm watching this whole like
right in front of me
um that was really heavy I've been
trying to see the film this week but
I've been moving so it's been a little
bit difficult for me to get in between
everything edge wise but I will be
seeing it on Saturday so appreciate it
guys cheers.com all right important it's
all good this is going to wrap up the
live portion of the show as we go to the
members only and when I said I would uh
give you the Super Chat Revenue we had
three thousand dollars in super chats we
now have twenty one thousand dollars in
super chats so uh I'm gonna click end
stream and we're gonna go to timcast.com
but uh I just asked my girlfriend to
bring up a personal check cause I'll be
writing you guys a check for forty two
thousand dollars wow wow
they're still super chatting at least
because now it's 44 000. all right we're
gonna go to timcast.com uh this has been
amazing we'll see you guys over there
thanks for hanging out